[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the MLB game of the week
pregame show presented by YouTube shorts
Houston Texas Minute Maid Park the site
of the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube Scott Braun see why Chris Young
and Brett Dolan gonna have the call for
you in about a half hour's time but what
you got to get you set for this pivotal
AL West matchup as the Astros won a
dramatic Fashion on Tuesday to extend
their lead into the division to six and
a half games in front of the visiting
Seattle Mariners luckily the trade
deadline has passed none of these
players will be traded for each other
it's Anderson and her Kitty the starting
pitchers and with that we say hello from
inside Studio 42 New Jersey Mike Lowell
World Series MVP I'm Stephen Nelson
Mikey with you okay you're say you just
walked out of the Mariner Dugout last
night kick in the shorts because you
were two outs away from cutting that
division lead back to four and a half
games you got a chance at this thing now
Alex bregman hits a bomb Carlos Correa
walks it off and now it's six and a half
it can be gut wrenching if you don't let
it affect today's game you know I think
that's the the big thing because when
you're playing these inner division it's
a two-game swing every day it's not hey
we won let's see how the team in front
of us is doing so I mean I look at it my
old high school coach David seglio would
say for the Astros guys the knife's in
now we turn it this is a chance for the
Astros to really step on their throat
and be like yeah you could have been
four and a half maybe three now you
might be seven and a half and now you're
talking as those games get shorter we're
at 23 24 games left in the season that
Gap is is starting to wind and if you're
seven games Houston can definitely sweep
the leg and sweep the series with a win
today in game number three but it's
tough for Seattle not only did they lose
Houston but it was on a night where New
York and Boston another two teams in
front of them in the Wild Card race also
lost I should have said spoiler alert
with the bregman Home Run and the crayo
walk-up because if you've missed it then
you didn't know that happened but here's
the highlights from last night just to
refresh your memory now it's up to
breitman he represents the tying run at
an RBI double in the third singled in
the fifth and bragman hits it high in
the air and deep to left field and you
can get the goodbye
off the community leader signs and we're
tied the runner at second for the Astros
is guriel Correa is one for four today
it'll bounce into the crowd and that'll
be a game-winner Astros win it
Robert Ford Henry kalis
hairy counts Todd callus on the calls
they're from a thrilling finish to last
night's game for the Houston Astros now
we show you the AOS standings the AL
standings in both the division in the
west and the wild cards you see the
stroke six and a half up on Seattle
Oakland has really hit a tough stretch
at an awful time got swept by the Jays
in Toronto then lost to the White Sox
and they are now falling down the
standings still three and a half games
back to the Wild Card Mikey but a ton of
teams in front of them yeah I think it
gets to the point when
the games might not mean as much as the
number of teams you have to jump right
someone someone's going to get hot you
know and I look at the Mariners and the
A's in that situation you might say well
we only have the Blue Jays and one
either the Red Sox or Yankees have to
you know falter a little bit but man
you're asking a lot to have two three
teams down the stretch where I think the
intensity increases the concentration
gets a little bit better The rosters are
expanding so if you're playing a bad
team they might be testing some young
guys out you know there's a chance to
really you know separate yourself in
that sense so each of these games I
think as these last three weeks play out
they become more and more important all
right Mikey it's time to unbox the
match-up head of our MLB game the week
here on YouTube Seattle and Houston
let's talk about both teams here and
let's begin with the Mariners because
there's been a lot of talk about them
throughout the year with the Run
differential they're like well what
about our fun differential the Run
differential on the record in one run
games it's not it's not sustainable but
here they are in the thick of it do you
feel like see Seattle is for real for
the postseason this year well the
standings tell me yes I tried to dig a
little deeper and I said you know I'm
going to find something that proves why
they're in it and I had a hard time you
know when I look at these are American
League stats offensively second to last
and Ops 12th in runs last in batting
average I'm like so how are they doing
okay let's go to the pitching side the
starter era is ninth their bullpen's
been very good yes fourth best so I'm
saying if they can kind of keep those
teams close they can Bridge it to the
bullpen and I think that kind of evens
the match up they just don't swing the
bats like the other teams in the
American League that are buying for
these playoff spots so it's it's hard
but you know can you say Well when they
lose they lose by a bunch and when they
win they win by a little bit and that's
why the Run differential can be skewed a
little bit I'm not so sure the numbers
don't tell me that but
the bottom line is Nelly they're winning
games yeah you know and it's okay I
don't really care how you win it right
yeah I don't at this point in the season
I'm not looking to what am I going to
map out for the future well there's
three weeks left in the future off
season we can look through you know
towards 2022 but as long as they can
creep and Claw and maybe those AL East
guys Red Sox and Yankee they beat up
each other a little bit they they both
have to play the Rays you know there is
that opportunity where someone can get
hot and a weekend can change things you
win three someone else loses three it's
a big swing in the division and I think
they have something like 10 games left
against a couple teams in front of in
the Wild Card standing so the
opportunity is there you talk about the
future it is seemingly bright you can't
like just Bank on that for Seattle but
the Futures looks bright and it also
seems stable now with the recent news in
the front office and in The Dugout you
know Scott service extended his manager
has done a tremendous job in The Dugout
for that club and then Jerry depodo
getting promoted and extended so now
these two working together that
collaboration have an opportunity to
build on the success that they've had
this season I I think from an
organizational standpoint on where you
want to go this is a great move you know
it's guys they're familiar with baseball
guys on on both ends I believe it's guys
that they feel like the Rapport is not
only with the players but that
communication
with upper management I think that's a
big deal today you know I think everyone
has to feel like they're on the same
page you know when I when I was coming
into the league I think sometimes you
felt like baseball Ops guys did their
thing and then field staff kind of did
their thing and now the that bridge has
to be gapped I mean that Gap has to be
bridged a lot more than before because I
think there are a lot of analytics and
things that need to be explained to
players on wide moves and why roster
construction is a certain way so I think
it does flow over into into the team and
when I look at guys and I see Jared
kelnick Mitch haniger Kyle Lewis I know
he's banged up even the second baseman
they picked up the Kendall graveman
trade had you know a couple I think
people were sour on that they picked up
Abraham yeah Abraham Toro like this kid
looks like a player so so you start
building that with success in the win
loss column and I think you can have a
real positive Snowball Effect in that
sense and something that you can kind of
empathize with relate to with the
Mariners you were part of a young team
in Florida that lost a lot and then
figured out how to win and so that's
something the guys in this Clubhouse are
maybe starting to do now that's
something that Houston has done sure you
know was losing franchise then won a
World Series and now look like another
postseason Juggernaut they were last
year kind of flip that switch do you
view them having that potential again
this year 100 I mean I I look at their
lineup construction and I love just how
Relentless they are you know they have
the the skill to put the ball in play
hit the ball with power I look okay what
do they bring from the left side I say
tucker I see Michael Brantley and I see
Jordan Alvarez I said wow that's great
but do they stack them one behind the
other no what do they have from the
right side you go guriel Altuve Correa
bregman it's like wow this is this is a
nightmare matchup for opposing pitching
staffs and and bullpens because you know
especially with the rule now that you
got to face you and the inning you've
got to face three in a row you're not
really going Lefty pull them out right
you can't so someone's facing a guy in a
more favorable position when I look at
the numbers it's like seven deep with an
Ops over 800. you know so it's it's a
Relentless attack with power it's not
just a bunch of guys that hey we're
going to flip a couple singles well the
singles team needs three hits to drive
in a run no these guys can you know
you're a bloop and a blast away always
from being in it so their offense when I
look at you know they're second in runs
second Ops first and on base percentage
third in slugging that's an elite
offense yeah you know so they they there
are a lot of things that they can do
well and they're at the other end of the
Run differential Spectrum compared to
their opponent Seattle Mariners one
member of that lineup That Mikey's
talking about Alex bregman is going to
join us in a little bit people always
mention this Houston lineup That Dusty
Baker kind of has at his disposal what
about the pitching staff I know the
bullpen has left a little bit to be
desired specifically the back end but
the starting rotation you know even
though no Justin Verlander and after the
departure of Garrett Cole they've had
some young guys step up and step in
um
I'm surprised that when I look at them
starter era is best in the American
League I don't know better than the
Chicago White Sox everyone's like oh the
Chicago White Sox they're so perfectly
planned you know they're perfectly form
formed to go into the postseason and
make a long run I just don't think it's
your typical household names you know
well you know McCullers is actually
having a real nice year granky's been
banged up I think that's more it sounds
like it's more of a precaution so those
are your two established names or Kitty
a couple years ago was huge in the World
Series you know this guy maybe not your
household name but a battle tested guy
you know we we can go down the list Jake
odorizzi Luis Garcia yeah you got guys
that the talents there and maybe it's
going to take a year or two before we
really know them as a name that you know
hey wow I don't want to face this guy
you know on uh Day game following a
night game you know but they're just not
there from name recognition perspective
you know I think the offense and the
stars that they have kind of overshadow
those guys but their starters have been
fantastic you can't get better so are
they primed for a postseason yeah I
think the balance on what they do on the
mound and offensively poses a lot of
problems it's tough for a team to beat
that team four times you know they also
just have guys when they get to that
October stage you just like Carlos
Caribbean one of them and the walk-off
hit last night that you just know that
they're going to do something when the
October lights are on let's throw this
poll question at you we know every time
we're together on the end of the game of
the week before the game starts we want
to ask who do you think's gonna win
simply put so this is our poll question
I'm in Seattle or Houston is it a sweep
for the Astros or to Seattle
to snap this little skid and start
chipping away at that Houston lead all
right we're stepping aside for a little
breathing when we come back special
guest Alex bregman we talked about it
now we'll talk to him next
[Music]
in the air to left field back on a Diaz
and he makes a nice diving catch Diaz to
the backhand
not a natural outfielder but making a
fine play in left field there on the
slicing deep-fly ball on the bat of
Abraham Toro
that ball popped in the air long run for
bregman he's the only one that can get
there and he does in pound territory
Alex bregman a nice play to end the
Innocence
strike three called runner on the go
that's a strike about throw mouth double
play
runner on the go the throw by stubs on
the money how about that Garrett Stubbs
popping out throwing a seed
Julie gariel hits one high and deep down
the left field line and this ball is
gone Yuli guriel La Pina cuts the lead
in half it's now a one-run game
now Carlos Correa swings and sends one
deep to center field that Ball's gone
back to back Jacks Julie gariel and
Carlos Correa and just like that the
game is tied at three two pitches two
bombs wow
foreign
welcome back to the MLB game of the week
pregame show presented by YouTube shorts
all right grab your chips and briggy
bomb salsa because it's been good since
Alex Breakman got back in the lineup
coming off the IL 357 clip four seven
the numbers you see them on the screen
they're all good let's talk about them a
little bit more with Alex bregman
himself who's joining us now ahead of
this game
Alex look I'm standing next to Mike
Lowell a champion like you World Series
MVP I got respect for Mikey so you get
the first question well thank you I have
a bias towards real good Third Base
baseball yeah fit that bill first of all
Alec I mean you've been on fire we saw
it since you've come back how's the
health how's the leg are you a hundred
percent
talk to us yeah yeah feeling great uh
thank you
um our uh our strength coaches and
training staff have uh done a really
good job of
um helping me out with a prep routine
and also just keeping me on the field
and healthy for these uh for this final
stretch run and it's been fun to be back
with the guys and just trying to
contribute in any way I can to uh help
us win a game we talk about contributing
it's one thing just being back it's
another thing announcing that you're
back like you did last night with that
kind of moment can you just walk us
through it
because seawall's been next
yeah he's one of the best he's one of
the best pitchers uh relievers in the
game and
um was just fortunate enough to put a
good swing on it he's got two uh really
really good pitches and
um
just yeah just tried to uh Square
something up use the middle of the field
and uh fortunately caught it a little
bit out front Alex last week you guys
went into Seattle they take two out of
three so coming here into Houston is
this a little bit of a statement series
that you know they're chasing you we
kind of want to put our stamp on this
series
I think these games are super important
for us uh not only uh for the division
but also just to start playing really
really good baseball down the stretch
and
um they're an extremely good ball Club
they got great pitching
um and uh to win those two games was was
huge but um today's another big one and
um looking forward to uh hopefully
trying to keep it rolling so Alex you're
well it was a special day around the
game of baseball with the Hall of Fame
ceremonies taking place up in
Cooperstown and people watch you your
fans notice that you wear number two and
think in part because that was where you
selected in the draft but also because
of one Derek Jeter so as you see the
captain going into Cooperstown just
wondering what kind of what's on your
heart and mind as somebody grew up
loving them
yeah it's super cool
um growing up in New Mexico uh my mama's
from New York actually so growing up New
Mexico she was always a big Yankees fan
and I always rooted for for Jeter and
love the way he played the game and
um just how he posted every day and
played played hard and left it all out
in the field so
um I've been a big fan of his
um since I started playing baseball and
uh that's super awesome today you and a
lot of people Alex I switched gears a
little bit let's talk about your manager
because I think there was a little bit
of uh I don't know a hesitation from a
lot of the baseball guys hiring Dusty
Baker because Houston was such an
analytics-based organization now this is
you know the players coach an old school
guy is there something about Dusty Baker
you've learned this year that maybe you
didn't know before
oh he loves this team
um he shows up every day and
um works his tail off to help us win
games and I think it's a perfect
combination of uh of the analytics and
and also the the baseball and uh
um it's really important to have have
baseball guys and
um Dusty's been awesome
um been helping us all and we we love
going out there and playing hard for him
to your point about loving the game and
working the last time we had an Astros
YouTube game I got to talk to your
teammate Kendall graveman and he took us
back to your days in the SEC he was
finishing up a hill state
and you were just getting started in
Baton Rouge and he remembered a series
where you made an error to potentially
cost the Tigers the game and what Graven
remembers is hours after the game where
the lights are still on at the stadium
and you were taking grounders from a
grad assistant do you remember that
story that grayman shared with us
yeah I think a ground ball went between
my legs and Mississippi State beat us
but uh but
um no yeah facing him in college uh he
was he was really really good and they
had a really good team actually uh Adam
Frazier was on that Squad I think Renfro
was on that score they have they have a
bunch of big leaders on that team and
then also Mississippi State won the won
the College World Series so us uh us
Tigers got to uh bounce back this year
uh and and take over the SEC again
Raven's been talking a lot of trash
my uncle went to LSU he's a huge fan
he's lived in Baton Rouge for 30 years
your football team took it on the chin
last week are we going to make it up
against McNeese State this Saturday
if they don't make it up against McNeese
State I don't know I don't know he's
going to be watching this is every home
game so this is a big one for you they
don't care McBee state or anything else
you got the Tigers got to take care of
business at home
it's a must win must win hey no I need
uh I need some tigers in my fantasy
football team I need Jamar Chase and
Odell Beckham to do well this year there
we go did hey did Garrett text you after
that UCLA win over LSU
no he didn't
um I I think he knows that I was I was
pretty uh upset he was that was very
classy with him I got I got plenty of
tech so I got plenty of text though just
yeah that it wasn't a good it wasn't a
good loss it was not Alex when we have
somebody on the YouTube pregame show
question we always want to ask is did
you ever did you or do you have a
favorite YouTube video of all time
um
I'm not sure uh
yeah I actually do um I got my favorite
YouTube my my favorite YouTube video is
uh Eric Thomas
um the hip-hop preacher he has a uh he
has a video of um
how bad do you wanna how bad do you want
it uh watched it every day when I was in
college and uh it's pretty motivational
if you haven't seen it go check it out
et's the man all right I like it got
something to do yeah there we go there
we go any final thoughts Mikey rooting
for you guys I mean this is in my
opinion the most balanced offense in the
American League do you feel like you
guys just present major match-up
problems it's power from the left side
power from the right side is that kind
of something you guys can take into the
postseason
yeah I I definitely I definitely believe
in this lineup and I think uh one of the
biggest things is the the power but also
the bat to ball skill and the and the
ability to walk and not strike out and I
think that's one thing that that plays
really well in the postseason is is
making contact because of how Elite the
pitchers are and
um I mean we we gotta we got a long way
to go to get there but
um I'm very confident in this lineup
down the stretch and
um I just want everybody to stay healthy
and and feel good going in hey before we
say goodbye I just want to relay a
message from realflow Robert Flores you
know Die Hard Astros fan and he's saying
I want salsa briggy bum salsa Lance
McCullers Jr told me that it's actually
truly great so roflow wants you to send
him some
yeah so a lot of people a lot of people
thought it wasn't going to be great but
it's legit uh I got I got some I'm gonna
send some to the MLB Network studio and
for everybody else who's watching this
they can go to braggybomb.com and grab
some here we go all right Alex bregman
back for the Houston Astros at the big
bomb in this series against the Mariners
looking to do more here on the YouTube
game of the week Frankie thanks so much
for the time man
all right have a good one guys thank you
let's turn that on the Creator Spotlight
once again shining on Kofi Ebola who is
of course the engagement editor for
secret base and if you're on the
internet's you know secret base isn't so
much of a secret wildly popular you know
coffee and I have been floating in like
internet Orbits for a long long time but
I've never gotten the chance to actually
talk to him let's change that right now
Kofi
awesome to finally do this so for those
who are uninitiated
with secret base tell us a little bit
about your channel and what you've been
working on
for us secret base is a channel of
sports storytelling
um we don't really deal with the
day-to-day like Sports Talk kind of
things we like to tell stories of old
through uh our video series we have a
thing called beef history we talk about
famous uh arguing so Bobby Bonilla by
Bonilla versus the Mets Dusty Baker
versus Tony larussa you know and then we
have a series called rinder where we
look at historic Sports moments and we
talk about all the things that led up to
said moment we also have other series
called Yorktown weird rules high score
and we kind of just rotate those
throughout the years
so that's what we do at secret base I
love working there it's just it's just
great wildly creative and I I mean
that's as simple as I can put it if you
haven't checked out the channel yet
please do so now uh Kofi you talk about
the beef history Bobby Bonilla and the
Mets how about the Mets and Mets fans
you being one of them uh but oh that
being said they're they're still hanging
around for a postseason spot do you have
belief or are you dead inside
uh I've been dead inside for years uh
it's been it's been years and years you
know where even though no matter how
it's I root for these teams where even
though
all this hope is spring Eternal it's
like in the back of the mind you're just
like is is this another gonna be another
letdown is this going to be another
disappointing season because the thing
is is that when you root for a team like
this you've seen it all yeah right
you've seen it all you've seen all the
hope so now you're like I root for this
team however at the same time I'm not
gonna put all of my chips in you know
all this stuff so it's it is what it is
like we know we were we were in first
place in the East for a little bit then
we had that slide and I was like there
it goes right now we're now they won on
my birthday which was yesterday so that
was good
um I was like okay so and we're close
that's the thing it's like we're never
like
it's like we're too close right it's
like close it's like uh it's like
Sisyphus put pushing the the ball or
rolling the rock up the hill and then
the rock just like magically falls down
every year every single year so Moses
Messina are producer right now he's also
a die-hard Met fan he's like this is so
true
um okay so you're in you're in New York
obviously the Mets are at one bro and a
different one you have the Yankees and
they're celebrating Derek Jeter their
Captain going into Cooperstown the Hall
of Fame today and you a secret base I
know okay let's talk about the video
that you just did let's talk about the
video who just did a secret base he did
a deep rewind on the famous flip plate
now we just have Buck show oil to walk
by and I work with him the other night
and he likes to say Jeter was late on
that play what was your big takeaway
from rewinding that back
I think that the thing about that play
that's most interesting is that there's
always this kind of debate on was it
necessary and was it effective right so
there's always you can always do this
estimation of like okay if Jeter doesn't
cut that ball off is Giambi out right or
is zombie actually out there's people
that argue that so it was kind of
interesting to look at this thing and
that's the thing it's like
it was an important play and the thing
is if Jeter cuts that ball off and then
Jambi is safe I feel like we'd be
talking about did Jeter even have to cut
that ball so it's a it's a very
interesting play like throughout uh
history that like you know it kind of
cemented his legacy as like he is going
to be like one of those all-time like
he's like a special player because like
I I've never seen someone cut the ball
off that close to The Catcher And then
it's like it's that's the right play to
do you know yeah all right last one from
me is there anything that you've seen in
baseball this year that you think one
day you would want to do a deep rewind a
deep dive or do a storytelling piece on
for secret base whether it's a player or
a team or a moment
um I am not sure yet I have I since I
don't work on the rewinders or beef
histories or anything like that I think
it'd be interesting so I actually will
I'll say this we are working on a fumble
Dimension that is revolving around a
certain player okay in in the American
League West I won't tell you who it is
okay is it bro I feel like people can
figure it
who knows who's to sing who's to say
that's what I call it secret base
because he's keeping it a secret that's
right again Kofi huge fan of your work
have been for a long time it's been
amazing to watch you blow up the way you
have and again for those who haven't
seen kofi's work in the team at secret
base please check it out but uh awesome
to link up with you man hope we could do
it again soon
absolutely anytime
there he goes Kofi Ebola oh look Tyler
Anderson one of the deadline pickups for
Jerry depoto he's been really good for
Seattle they need him to be good again
today
foreign
[Applause]
got a chance
Fair ball yes indeed Kyle Seeker scores
and the Mariners have a 6-5 lead that
was a big hit
and on the ground base hit
right field Corner JP walks on Mitch
strolls home Kyle Seeger Chuck Shing
5-3 Seattle
nothing Mariners ball game
[Applause]
the Mariners
high drive right field
got big time carry Splash that baby
three round armored Kyle singer 8-5 lead
for the Mariners
he drills this drilled and crushed and
this is gone
wanted at bat wonder what the vibe of
the clubhouse will be tonight
4-0 Mariners
foreign
game of the week pregame show presented
by YouTube shorts it's time now for
picks to click
presented by bet MGM
Mike Lowell Steven Nelson here inside
Studio 42 one question for you Mike as
we're watching a nail Clash here in the
game of the week who is your pick to run
the table in the American League
wow I'm gonna sound like a front runner
but the rays are so deep hey there's
something wrong with being chalky if
it's right yeah I mean they're they they
hit they can pitch they beat up on good
teams they destroy bad teams
I got the raise and they never say die I
think they have 43 comeback wins this
season you just can't kill Tampa Bay
they're no longer this upstart this is a
juggernaut in the American League
so as we go from Mikey's pick to click
we now want to show you your poll
results we asked you who you thought was
going to win the game of the week here
on YouTube Seattle or Houston 65 Mike
going with that yeah I'm okay with that
yeah home team coming off a great win
two-thirds of the guys no problem I'm
with him I know today yeah it's got that
feeling today that uh this week anyway
that Houston is just going to make a
statement but the big game for the
Mariners massive it is a huge game they
got to bounce back from from a lot you
know there are losses that are gut
wrenching and some that we were never in
it last night was gut wrench again two
outs away this stuff hey flush it Mikey
said to them stop the show flush it
don't let it turn into a bad one loss
turn into two all right we're done here
Scott Braun Chris Young and Brett Dolan
have the call and then we'll be game of
the week Live on YouTube
games
[Applause]
oh they love Hardball in downtown
Houston and the home team has been
rewarding their fans for years with big
success inside this ballpark this year
more of the same and it's not just the
playoff appearances but even a night
like last night a comeback walk-off
against a Relentless division foe this
is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube shorts the
Seattle Mariners are in town to clash
with the Houston Astros for some
Wednesday baseball at Minute Maid Park
and the shows have built a six and a
half game cushion in the AL West thanks
to wins in the first two games of this
set these two will close the book on
their season series today Oakland's
collapsing they've dropped four in a row
the wild card is where the drama's at in
the AL postseason picture the M's are
involved with just a few games to make
up and a few weeks to go oh this is
going to be real good Scott Brown along
with the former All-Star Chris Young
great to see you and also you liked the
playing in this ballpark a little bit a
little bit a little bit I think if we
pull up my numbers up I have some good
times out here okay good I think we're
gonna pull his numbers up at some point
but let's start with numbers for the
Seattle Mariners and I will say their
general manager Jerry depoto has talked
about this team having a short memory
well keep it really short because we can
go a long way when it's talking about a
playoff drought that is longer than any
in professional sports at the moment
this team was awesome in 01 yeah we'd
have to go all the way back to 2001 and
this is a team I would think you've seen
Randy Johnson Griffey A-Rod but no none
of those guys were there they did have
Ichiro they did have Edgar Martinez
Brett Boone Mike Cameron this was a team
that played great defense had great
pitching and the lights out Bullpen and
then the rain came for a long long time
see why this team still has a drought
that they're hoping to wipe away this
season it's possible eventually when the
rain does clear it's going to be
glorious although it's not the 2001 team
this team is built completely different
but they're bunched with a group of
young players Scott service has come in
and taken a group a young young guys and
allowed them to come out and have fun
play the game compete play great defense
and find ways to win close games so
there's two mottos I see one on the
screen why not us and the other is it's
been a minute but they're working on it
okay longest active play out playoff
droughts among the four major North
American Pro Sports well the Mariners at
the moment take the cake and all the
rain I guess they're due right yeah
that's a good way to put it okay
to love averages the Mariners are due
and they do have a young exciting ball
Club but yes it's been a minute while
the Houston Astros have seen a ton of
success in their organization where even
last year they had success but it was a
weird 2020 not just for them for
everybody it was a weird 2020 for them
for multiple reasons number one we have
to admit you're coming off the cheating
scandal the pressure was on the Astros
they didn't have berlander they didn't
have Alvarez Correa had a very down year
coming off of the year in 2019 which
everybody got questioned Altuve was in
the same boat coming out people were
questioning what team is this team what
are the Astros made of 2021 they come
back strong and they're doing what
they're always done yeah and that is
raking good pitching Elite defense they
barely have any weaknesses I can't seem
to find too many of them I mean when you
look at this offense it's arguably the
best offense in the game they're strong
from top to bottom and you have Kyle
Tucker in the seven hole six hole
tonight breckman's back off the um off
the DL they're they're playing great
defense they're pitching well
they're the team to beat you can see the
fewest strikeouts that's on the hitting
side then on the pitching side this
despite what we showed you at the note
not okay Corral with no Verlander and of
course they lost coal a couple years ago
top five in starting pitching era in the
league at three and a half and there's
the defense it doesn't it doesn't take
the superstars but colors are Kitty
going tonight Luis Garcia I mean going
for rookie of the year they are strong
from top to bottom I don't even know
what their team's gonna look like in the
playoffs because they have so many
strong suits at the top of the lineup
they're gonna Dusty's gonna have some
decisions to make you're right that's
what this time period is all about guys
like Jose or Kitty who's pitching today
is he going to be good enough to crack
the playoff rotation we'll find out soon
and you mentioned Korea the spotlight
has been on him all season long and for
more on Carlos Correa let's kick it to
the third member of our team Brett Dolan
has more
thanks Scott Carlos Correa was indeed
the hero last night a walk-off double in
Extra Innings as the Houston Astros took
down the Seattle Mariners now Carlos has
been a key part of this franchise over
the last several years and for the fans
they're curious about what his future
looks like here in H-Town we were here
two weeks ago when Carlos's quotes came
out in the athletic regarding his future
speaking almost in past tense trying to
win another championship to lead this
organization with two of them now with
Brian McTaggart about a week later he
cleaned things up saying obviously I do
not have a contract for next year who
knows he would be happy to stay here if
need be if not he'll go play for
somebody else now when free agency is
looming you wonder what that might do to
somebody mentally well Carlos is he
pressing or not certainly he got off to
a very good start as you'll see in April
and June at 296 15 home runs almost 50
RBIs since then 51 games he said 251
with just seven home runs now Dusty
Baker has an explanation Carlos was sick
around the All-Star break he said he was
very weak it wasn't covet didn't feel
like he was quite the same hitter but
things have changed now I did ask Dusty
whether or not he takes the temperature
of Carlos just to see where he is and he
says yes but not mentally physically
Carlos wants to play a lot of games
wants to keep him in the lineup and
maximize his help but he is hoping that
last night is the key going forward more
of those big time hits to win games for
this team in September and Beyond
Minuteman Park is the side of our
YouTube game of the week roof close
today our lineup's in our first pitch
coming up the Mariners at Astros on
YouTube
foreign
ERS first pick swing at JP Crawford
stings a single into right
and there's a base hit and shoots to the
right side JP Crawford is aboard
the opposite way and away from the
shifts Crawford is two for two
on the ground Crawford pops up
couple of Skips plenty of time keeps a
run off the board and ends the top of
the third what a play by JP Crawford
oh my back up the middle Crawford put
that on the Button he's aboard for the
first time now the Mariners have the go
ahead run on base
JP hitting the ball pretty well and
getting good results lately with this
heading straight and it continues right
here on the third pitch of the ball game
the other way and JP continues to thrive
doing that gastianos can't believe it
Jake B Crawford cruising in the second
with the Devil is two for two
he goes the other way base hit gilmick
scores marmo right behind him and JP
Crawford what a day
[Applause]
this is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube shorts
watching create videos on YouTube try
shorts in the YouTube app on your phone
Scott Braun with Chris Young and Brett
Dolan and we do a lot here on YouTube on
a weekly basis and we're thrilled to
have you join us here and be part of the
party and also our latest feature allows
you to control the audio you can
personalize your listening experience
it's the multi-track audio hang out with
us you can click for the home or the
Radio Calls mix it up do whatever you
want you do you on the speakers tell
your friends youtube.com MLB it's free
for everyone to watch today on MLB's
YouTube channel we have miked up players
Dugout interviews the whole deal and
let's get this game rolling with Jose or
Keady matching up against Tyler Anderson
your starting pitchers and both of them
actually have quite a few similarities
Cy a lot of similarities we got two four
pitch guys today but we'll start off
with our kitty he's the fourth seam
slider change up curve guy he's using
his fourth scene majority of the time
about 55 percent of the time so he's
trying to establish that fastball early
in the game and then get guys to chase
after he gets that established and I
mean he's in the top five and lowest
averages with that change up so I expect
to see that change up quite a bit today
Mariners need to take this one they
dropped the first two in this series
let's go over the keys to the game on
the Seattle side for the visiting ball
Club brought to you by YouTube shorts so
for the Mariners they just have to stay
within striking range I mean they're
leading the league in Major League
Baseball in one run games with 29 wins
so if they if they can stay close
throughout the game they'll be in a good
position to get to that Bullpen Anderson
he has to bring out the paintbrush today
he has to stay away from the middle of
the play he's not a big below guy at 90
miles an hour with his fastball he needs
to stay from the middle of the plate and
Seeger I see him being clutch in a big
situation today Arcadia reverse split
guy to where lefties don't hit him as
well Seeger's gonna come up in a big
situation he's the leader in that
Clubhouse and they go as he goes and now
let's run through the YouTube shorts
lineup card for the visiting Seattle
Mariners they check in at 75 and 64 on
the season JP Crawford will lead the way
then haniger Seeger is having a monster
second half power wise Ty France can do
it all at the plate Toro was the big
trade pickup torens is the DH today
kelnick is the Brookie with big promise
Tom Murphy will catch and hit eighth and
Jose marmalejos in the nine spot
foreign
looks around ready to go just activated
off the injured list for a start against
San Diego this is start number two since
then and we are underway to a global
audience on YouTube today
there's Crawford's excellent on base
percentage during an eight game on base
Street
he fouls back the 1-0 so Jose arcadi
checks in with the 342 era on the season
and he'd been out since June 29th with
right shoulder discomfort left the game
against Baltimore after an inning and a
third that was the second time he had
left an outing with that issue
Crawford drives one to right field
there's Tucker
floating back
he makes the catch
so kitty pop back up against San Diego
two runs four in a third 71 pitches he
went two times through the order this is
the Arsenal that he's working with a lot
of four seam fastball slider and change
up and he's a reverse splits guy at
statcast 3D powered by Google Cloud
hooks us up with his Arsenal
I see him using that change up hopefully
a little more today especially with four
lefties in the lineup today for Seattle
and lefties have struggled greatly
against his change up so I see him
pulling that out in pressure situations
to where he needs a big out
Mercede has had
Big Time results with his change up
I see him being aggressive in the zone
early we're talking to Dusty Baker
before the game today and he's coming
off the on the IL had a good start his
first start
trying to establish early trying to stay
in this game as long as he can because
there's a good chance he's going to be
on the pitch count I like what his
manager Dusty Baker told us this morning
as we check out the odds courtesy of bet
MGM first off I'll tell you that quote
in a moment the Mariner's going up or
down on three and a half runs today what
do you think
I I have both teams swinging the bad
well today I'm gonna go over over okay
cutting a Miss there from haniger and
give you the line from Dusty this
morning on his starter he said he can
throw strikes in his sleep if anything
maybe throw a few less strikes which you
never hear about pitchers how it tastes
and you always have guys like that to
where you know if you get in a situation
to where you have three balls on you if
you're hitting in that situation you
just assume he's gonna throw you a
strike which sometimes works in your
favor and makes guys expand their Zone a
little bit it's dusty in his 24th Big
League season managing he's been in the
game for many decades 72 years old
that's pulled off the third base bag
it's a fair ball and a base hit for
Mitch haniger
Marvin Gonzalez handling the Hot Corner
today and not much you can do about that
one I think the bag may have played good
defense right there may have saved the
double that's true
first start for Marvin Gonzalez since
signing a minor league contract on
August 27th there he is beloved by both
the fan base and
by his teammates
bregman getting the day off after the
big Homer last night
last night was epic for the Astros
Alex bregman
hits a game-tying two-run home run in
the ninth inning off Paul Seewald who
had been money this season oh he's
enjoying the day off put the feet up get
comfortable you'll be there you'll be
there until about the sixth or the
seventh and you better start getting
loose
there was Carlos Correa with the
walk-off double in extras that one is
looks like off the mound this time and
it's going to turn into another infield
knock marwin Gonzalez has to eat up the
baseball and Kyle Seeger is aboard have
you ever seen that before one off the
base then one off the rubber not on
back-to-back plays
and there's a good chance that that's a
double play ball
I mean you see Correa right there behind
the base right there behind the mound he
flipped it off his foot yeah he fills
that ball steps on second throws the
first
ending over just like that
you heard the little click sound if it
was off his foot
do you make sure he's okay I mean
Kitty's not flinching so he normally
looked to The Dugout you give him a nod
I'm fine let's keep the game rolling
he's a guy that likes to pick up the
pace
Kitty is ready to go when he gets the
baseball he fires a strike to tie
friends who's hitting 340 since August
10th
and second best in the American League
to
the magical wander Franco the super
rookie on the Tampa Bay Rays
Ty France he's he's not a huge name not
a guy that he does that a lot of people
know but he hits
opposite field knock he uses the entire
field and now the Mariners have loaded
up the bases here in the First with just
one out it's a great piece of hitting
right there he's a San Diego State Guy
taught by the late great Tony Gwynn he's
able to hit the ball all over the field
consistently put together good at bats
not expand the Zone stay in the strike
zone
and to see a big guy do that hit it all
over the field go the other way it's
nice to see that's why he's in that four
hole
I don't think there's many players that
Astros fans would go oh not this guy but
Abraham Toro fits the mold as he digs in
with the bases loaded
biggest hit I would say of his life at
this point was a Grand Slam against this
Astros team in a win about a week and
change ago
he has been a different ball player
since putting on this uniform
nice I mean I know he struggled a little
bit when he was with Houston earlier in
the year but when you get traded to
another team who was in playoff
contention you have the pressure on you
there's a little backlash from it
you want to go over there and make a
good impression so for him to come out
and start hitting right away had to take
a huge weight off his back allow him to
go out there and have fun he's continued
to play well in this situation with with
Seattle I mean I think they have the
highest OPS in baseball with runners in
scoring position
so you're trying not to let this game
get out of hand too early we're in the
first inning you don't want this to
happen no Deja Vu says all of Houston at
the moment because on August 31st in
Seattle Abraham Toro with a grand slam
Smash and that was the difference in the
ball game for the Mariners
Genie gets a swing and Miss it's a
one-two count on Toro so that was the
big trade right near the deadline
Toro heading over to Seattle along with
Joe Smith Kendall greatman was the big
pickup in the bullpen for the Astros
along with Rafael Montero and actually
timing wise it was coming off a big win
for Seattle and Craven was a huge part
of the bullpen so it didn't look great
timing wise but Jerry depoto explained
Toro fouls that one back the deal had to
be made on that very day and here's why
Montero was the key he was designated
for Simon by the Mariners the Astros
wanted him and if they had waited
another day Montero would have been
available to anyone on waivers so the
deal had to get done even though the
timing wasn't the prettiest there's so
many things that happened behind the
scenes that us as fans or us even in the
game just don't know about
Toro rips one to right field plenty of
open space he's in business and the
Mariners crack the scoreboard for first
here's haniger and Seeger will score as
well it's a two RBI two bagger for
Abraham Toro and he continues to punish
his former Squad
gotta put a slide a smile on your face
early in the game
is that a changeup left up in the zone
yeah we have the change up you see the
three fingers right there that's his
go-to pitch right there right there
you're assuming that you want to get it
out with your best pitch against the
left-handed bat Turtles able to stay
through that ball get it up just high
enough and put the barrel on and hit it
to the right field line
Altuve is like dude take it easy on us
11 games against Houston for Toro
six extra base hits 14 RBIs he has been
a lightning rod in the lineup for the
Mariners
this is a player they picked up in a
trade too a different one but it's also
working out for them Luis Torrens
in his last 20 games
hitting close to 300.
the game that you're always making
adjustments you had a slow start to the
year ended up getting option down but in
mid June came back up and has been
swinging to bed well ever since
sometimes when you have those up and
down moments through a season you're
able to make adjustments clear your mind
and come out ready to go
France at third Toro at second you
mentioned this team being excellent with
runners in scoring position well they're
two for two with runners in scoring
position here in the first
hitters 2-0 cap for torens
he lays off a pitch inside it's 3-0
because you need to find a way to get
back into this account not sure if he's
trying he's okay with the walk here
getting the runner getting the runner on
first base you have to base open try to
get the double play ball
four pitches and a free pass for Terence
MLB's YouTube channel Santoro against
the Astros since the trade has been
crazy True Story I mean that trade was
highly criticized not just locally but I
would say on a national level just
because of the way it looked Optics wise
you're trading away maybe your best
reliever is the team that was very much
involved in a playoff run and still are
they're three games out of his spot
nobody knows about Abraham turo he's
kind of buried on the bench for the
Astros and look at him go
that's when you have to trust your guys
in the front office you have to trust
trust the plan that the Mariners are
trying to put themselves in a position
to be really good for the upcoming years
and to do that yeah you have Graven for
the rest of the season but what do you
do for next year so Toro is a guy that
you can have he comes over swings the
back well you have hopefully a second
baseman maybe a third baseman up for the
future and you have Team control of them
for a while as well so it's so many
things that go into these decisions that
front officers make and it's tough for
the players to deal with them sometimes
but you just have to trust the process
it Toro is under team control through
2026. they're looking to build something
with longevity in Seattle and they're
hoping this young man at the plate is a
big part of that Jared Kelly
takes a pitch low it's another Miss
for Kitty and Christian Javier is
getting warm in the Houston Bullpen
we're here in the first
good news for the Astros is they're off
tomorrow so you can
empty out the relief pitching group
if need be and that's another missed
spot for Keating which is really rare to
see from him this is like I mentioned a
guy who can wake up and throw strikes he
can and he still can throw strikes in
this situation what he's hoping right
there is that kelenetic heck's been
scuffing a little bit hopefully hoping
that he would expand his Zone a little
bit so great job by killing it to stay
within himself
he's the type of that bats where if
you're a young guy and you've been
scuffing quite a bit throughout the
season these are the type of the bats
early in the game that you can have that
can turn this last month of last month
of the Season around for you come
through in a clutch situation like this
kick them while they're down
even if it's just a walk
that's a good at bat that's an RBI
keep the line moving
and the plate discipline has been there
for kelnick in his minor league career
it's been a lot of swing and Miss in his
game in the majors nice stop there by
Maldonado to prevent a run from coming
across
it was after the 3-1 got under it
and Tucker's coming in close enough that
it's not going to be doable for a tag-up
and it's just a fly ball out
Kelly Nick worked himself into a
favorable position right there got a
good pitch to hit just jammed himself up
a little bit I mean that was a good
pitch
to put the barrel on and sometimes when
you're just a little bit off get
extended too early and you jam yourself
a little bit
and you see that ball running in on his
hands just a little bit but in a hitters
count
if you're feeling right you're ready for
that pitch
catcher number eight hitter Tom Murphy
27 pitches in this first inning from
Jose arcadi so far
strike to just two of
tickets one and one I mean if he gets
out of this with just two runs allowed
it's a big big win on his side after the
way that this inning started if you can
get out of this you get back to the
Dugout you settle in you come back you
let those two runs go you come out and
start fresh and you trust your offense
to be able to recoup Those runs
Murphy in the air
[Applause]
he's got it yeah it's going to be a big
win when it comes down into the glove of
Carlos Correa
a four hit two run first for the
Mariners they loaded up the bags a
couple times it could have been much
worse the two RBIs of course registered
to the account of Abraham Toro the
trades working out for both sides bottom
of the first coming up
[Music]
foreign
that's a base hit in the right field
around third comes Yuli guriel he's
going to score this game tied up at
three RBI single Kyle Tucker
runner on the go and Tucker called safe
on a pitch just off the plate
Kyle Tucker drives one dig to right
field and gone two run home run Kyle
Tucker Astros take the lead by three in
the eighth that ball was demolished nice
little back flip at the end of that for
him
as Tucker Hits one pretty well to right
field all the way back is Myers and
he'll watch it go
home runs winning the game last night
and
at the night holy Tucker he is seeing
some fastballs and he is demolishing
some fastballs
breaking ball Tucker goes the other way
fam giving it a look in this ball
there and in play now it bounces into
the crowd that'll be a double for Kyle
Tucker showing power to all fields
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube shorts and
they also present this Astro starting
nine with all the big boys in there
besides bregman Altuve Brantley duriel
Jordan Carlos Correa with dynamite
numbers against Seattle this season Kyle
Tucker in the sixth spot oh Astros fans
you're spoiled Jake Myers has been a
super rookie marwin Gonzalez is back
with the strohs and Martin Maldonado
will catch and hit nine
Tyler Anderson on the mound left-handed
pitcher era at 4-3-5 he's been even
stronger since the Mariners picked him
up another shrewd move by the front
office
Tyler Anderson here another four pitch
guy similar to her kitties a four-seam
cutter Change-Up Sinker guy the
difference of the two I mean his V
lowest fastball Velo is around 90 miles
an hour what he's been able to do all
year long though is create opportunities
for swinging misses he's expands the gun
expands The Zone hitters Chase and they
know that he throws a lot of strikes
which is what allows Altuve to be very
aggressive in that situation he knows
that he throws a lot of strikes
and clearly Jose altube was aware went
after the first pitch popped out to the
shortstop J.P Crawford now statcast 3D
powered by Google cloud with that
Arsenal that you were going over a lot
of four seed cutter change up and Scott
service told us the cutter is as good as
it's ever been for him right now it's
becoming more and more of a weapon
and that's what you have to do to keep
hitters off balance if you're a guy who
throws a lot of fastballs in you and
you're throwing 90 miles an hour you
need something to get guys off the
barrel
and this is something that pitchers like
CeCe Sabathia were able to do later in
their career they threw a lot of
straight fastballs but they needed some
type of deception to get guys off the
barrel and that's why he's using this
cutter in different situations you see
on the graphic right there that he has
curveball that he throws from time to
time but talking to service before the
game he knows that he's a Fly ball
pitcher and he knows that that curveball
is a ball that guys hitting hitting the
air and in a stadium like this admit it
made you don't want too many balls in
the air yeah that's not a pitch he's
going to dial up very frequently
it's just for fun
one to Brantley
it's a ball in two strikes
this was a huge resigning in the off
season for Houston Mr consistency 300
plus since 2018 and he signed up for
this and next year with the stros
Brantley is just a guy year in and year
out he gives you consistent at bats
he never tries to do too much he's very
quiet at the dish not too much movement
so with that being said he's able to
replicate his move time and time again
stay through the middle of the field and
come through in big situations all the
time because he never changes his
approach
they call him Uncle Mike in Houston he's
a mentor for many
and he makes contact on the 1-2 a nice
stop by France at first to the covering
Anderson for the out Ty Francis played
some sneaky good first base D this year
foreign
[Applause]
France is a guy that he had to work on
his defense he was originally in the
middle of the infield he had to work on
his defense and he's arguably the best
first base in England in the game right
now with defensive run saves at three
which is crazy I mean the Mariners also
we're fortunate to have Evan White in
that spot and he's been down this year
with an injury but
Thai Francis more than filled the void
not only on defense of course he's been
a great bat for the team but Scott
service made it a point this morning to
tell us about how good Ty Francis looked
on a daily basis at the position and
there he goes showing us what it's all
about here in the first
now Yuli guriel
taking a strike on the outside corner
and back to France real quick with
service when you lose a gold glove first
baseman it has to mean so much for your
team to be able to replace him with
another Goga Gold Glove caliber player
OH
Anderson working both sides of the zone
you know I can't look away from the
delivery too you mentioned the deception
with the cutter but
there's the pitch again
Tyler engine almost looks like he's
starting up his bike with his foot gets
a swing and miss and a strikeout to end
the frame on a 10 pitch first inning
three up three down against a very
potent Astros lineup Mariners carry
their two-nothing lead into the second
foreign
on the ground Toro can't handle it
Correa is in meanwhile guriel is right
behind him he scores also two runs RN
and the Astros lead it two nothing with
nobody out of the second tires getting
the start in center field coming off a
road trip or hit 300. he drives what
they to left field forget about it three
run Bomb by the rookie Jake Myers and
the Astros jump out in front five to
nothing here's Alvarez nice man the bat
in the frame and Alvarez whistles this
one deep to right center field and
that's going to get down for a base hit
and go all the way to the wall Altuve
scores Alvarez trades places with him
he's at second with an RBI double six
nothing Astro
Jordans 90th run batted into the season
Runners at the corners no one out for
Tucker
drills this one into left center field
that will be down for a hit past the
diving Jared kelnick Correa scores Here
Comes guriel he'll be waved home he's
going to score two RBIs double for Kyle
Tucker and the Astros in double figures
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's two nothing Seattle in the end of
this season series between the Astros
and the M's they also made a trade on
July 27th braveman and Montero to boost
the bullpen for Houston and Joe Smith is
added to the bullpen mix for Seattle
along with the now great Abraham Toro
and that's the Ops heading into today
where he's already contributed an extra
base hit and two more RBIs so our first
poll question is very relevant who got
the better of that deal Astros Mariners
it's a wash or too soon too soon
what do you think
I would say as of right now you would
assume that the Mariners got the best
better end of the deal but that could
change very fast if this continues to go
on the Astros go to the playoffs
graven's coming out late in the game to
close out to close out A Big World
Series game I mean that argument could
easily switch to the other side right
now it's so easy to say Seattle but you
just don't know what the future holds
Toro has been smashing the baseball for
the Mariners graveman is a big part of
the back end of the pen now
her Kitty delivers another strike there
to marmolejo's in the nine spot I think
the other thing to keep in mind not
included in that trade is the
acquisition of Diego Castillo to help
out the Seattle Bullpen and fill that
void left by graveman
and that Bullpen is what has allowed
them to be in the position that they are
right now without that lights out
Bullpen that the Mariners have service
is handcuffed and they would not be in
the position that they are right now and
able to win all of those one-run games
help us out with the poll question right
now four choices it's posted on your
computer screen mobile device whatever
it is that's in on the hands of
marmalejos
and into the glove of the rookie Jake
Myers for the first out
it was a first inning full of traffic
for Seattle after JP Crawford flew out
there's Mitch haniger Off Third Base
back I think that was off her Kitty's
foot he was like where did it go that
was Seeger with the infield knot then
France contributing the opposite field
hit to load up the bases Toro brings two
home with the double corens follows with
a walk helmick flew out and Murphy
popped out so two runs they loaded up
the bases a couple times but they left
them loaded as well Mariners come out of
the First with two runs off Jose arcadi
and we'll see if he bounces back here in
the second inning
second time through the order for Kitty
this is Crawford again
Crawford able to put together a great at
bat Last Night Big Moment of the game
Big Two Out RBI 3-2 count pitch off the
plate able to stay through the middle of
the field and continue to be clutch for
this Mariners offense
two of the keys the Mariners will tell
you to them being involved in the
playoff picture right now despite just
okay overall team stats Bullpen like we
talked about and the
money with runners in scoring position
Crawford's one of those that leads the
pack is 333 in those spots doesn't have
one of those positions at the moment but
hey rather be better with guys on than
nobody on and he's been very valuable to
this Mariners organization on both sides
of the ball
talking to Scott before the game he
called he considered Crawford's
quarterback of the infield although you
have Seeger there as the leader of the
team
him and Crawford on that left side of
the infield
and just snuck a bunt it's a foul ball
not a load up to count for Crawford all
right YouTube creators help us out here
Pole's still going we'll keep it open
for about an inning but secret base is
actually our creator Spotlight we'll
talk more about them later I think the
real answer is toro got the best end of
it that's true Abraham Toro has
blossomed that's a great point right
there sometimes you can get caught up as
in a log Jam as a young player with the
organization that's always in playoff
contention
Crawford spins one to left field
Brantley chasing it towards the line in
the corner makes the catch for the
second out
if you think the Astro is going to have
to do today
to continue to be great to continue to
come back and try to win this game
first thing they're going to have to do
for my key points they're going to have
Anderson he has to throw strikes you
have to make them throw strikes today he
has the third highest Chase rating in
the major league baseball throwing 90
miles an hour if the Astros who don't
strike out a lot are able to get him in
the middle of the Zone they'll be just
fine today they have one of the best
defense in the game you have Korea and
Al tube up the middle of the field
continue to play good defense and keep
the line moving the line line is so deep
you have Tucker in the six hole today
you're never out of the woods with this
offense so continue to keep the line
moving don't try to beat a hero and
allow your offense to just do its thing
ball and strike to haniger you're right
yesterday trailing by a couple runs
you're in the ninth inning oh Alex
bregman's up oh by the way we have this
guy waiting in the wings who just came
off the DL hasn't gone deep since June
but don't forget don't forget who he's
been for our organization he didn't
forget
oozing with confidence
I'm looking at some of Korea's
statements after the game it's like that
offense new everybody in the Dugout knew
that bregman was about to come through
in that situation he's facing Seawall
who missed with some sliders quite
pretty big sliders and he had to come
with the fastball and bregman although
he had no homers off the fastball this
season he was able to come through in
that situation
this would be a nice recovery for Jose
rikidi that's fouled off
the only thing is the pitch count but
like I said when you have a pretty
rested Astros Bullpen and you have an
off day tomorrow for Houston so even if
her key only goes four or five innings
really even four at this point
based on him still working his way back
from the injured list they'll be in good
shape one two swinging a miss
there you go after a four or two run
four hit first from Seattle it's three
up three down from Jose arcadi as we
bounce into the middle of the SEC
to ask nobody on no score
all right see what happens second time
through for the Astros
altube hooks one deep down the left
field line this ball is gone home run
Jose Altuve his first home run since
July 30th and the Astros lead one to
nothing be a lot of fun to watch this
guy get hot down the stretch Kyle Seeger
leads off here top six
this is pummeled out to right Kyle
Seeger leaving the yard and putting the
Mariners in front two run Mariners lead
in the ninth inning now it's up to
breitman he represents the tying run had
an RBI double in the third singled in
the fifth and bregman hits it high in
the air and deep to left field and you
can get the goodbye
off the community leaders signs and
we're tied the runner at second for the
Astros is Uriel Correa is one for four
today
there's a ball into right field hit well
that'll be ahead of haniger
[Applause]
hook up double by Correa just what he
does TK gets big hits
[Applause]
[Music]
okay let me fill you in on this new
feature that I mentioned probably 10-15
minutes ago fans watching the MLB game
of the week Live on YouTube right here
have your choice of listening experience
and we're showing you how to do it
that gear icon in your player has an
audio tracks button you can select
primary that's us home away radio call
go back and forth do what you want it's
all synced up seamlessly integrated on
your favorite devices you won't miss a
minute of the action it's all right
there for you a little new feature right
here on YouTube on a weekly basis Scott
Brown Chris Young Brett Dolan hanging
out with you on a Wednesday afternoon
Mariners and Astros playing against each
other in the regular season for the
final time in 2021 Alvarez Correa and
Tucker do up here in the second against
Tyler Anderson who pours in a strike
Alvarez has been such a polished hitter
from his first time in the league he was
a guy that I played against
sometimes you sit back and awe on how a
young player can be so quiet and so
confident at the dish
he looks like a veteran it's he looked
like a veteran as soon as he stepped
into the box for his first season
he also looks like a power hitter this
is a big strong dude
and strong contact past the shifted
infielder
Toro was in a somewhat correct spot but
it was smoked off the bat of Alvarez and
he starts off the second with a single
that's what you call hitting it through
the shift right there
oh you're shifting me I don't care
you're playing me in Shallow right field
I can hit it just hard enough to get by
you
nice effort by Toro
you're going we're gonna back you up 30
feet for moments like this
and yet Alvarez still comes through
now it's Korea
Mr walk-off man from yesterday in the
10th
it's a lead off walk-off double in the
10th yesterday
Runner placed on second base to start
extras
and it only took one batter to end the
game on Houston's side
Correa putting together another really
good season it's nice to see him stay
healthy you know throughout the year
it's a big year for him came out the
gates hot he slowed down a little bit
but even his slow down is still very
productive
and it continues to come through and
collect situations like this one last
night added to the resume
good mustard on that one
and
the seats ground Rule automatic double
game Ender Astros ticket
[Applause]
some players just have what it takes and
they're able to to dig down deep in big
situations slow the game down slow the
heartbeat down and come through big in
situations Korea has always been that
type of player
he rips that one right into the glove at
the hot corner of Kyle Seeger wow
[Applause]
can't wait to see this exit V low
that's rocket retrieval right there
that's when you go into the Dugout and
everybody says nice swing
and you're like man I'm not trying to
hear that that should have taken his
glove off of his hand right there
112 miles an hour off the bat will get
you a right turn back to the Dugout I'll
take the jam shot up the middle any day
gold Glover
at third base Gold Glove left side of
the infield for Seattle
see that was a play made by someone who
has been at the position for a long time
and it was evident there
and you you see even Seeger right there
had a smile on his face like wow
look what I found
still have to wear with all to throw to
first base try to get the double play
the defense in this series for Seattle
hasn't been the smoothest mostly talking
about the Outfield so you need a game
like this Tucker into left Center
kelnick chasing it and it's going to hop
up against the wall Alvarez heading for
third and he's being waved home and here
he comes throw is
not in time the Astros are on the board
it's an RBI double for Kyle Tucker to
bring home Alvarez and make it two to
one
Kyle Tucker just continues to stay hot
Dusty Baker loves him in the position
that he's at some guys have their best
years if you're playing well in the
sixth hole or seven hole there's no need
to always move somebody up in the lineup
you allow them to settle in in their
position within the lineup and continue
to do damage
you see that ball head into the Gap
that's a tough play for counting to make
I mean the way Minute Maid Park is built
over here all those little nooks and
crannies there's no way he could have
made that play and the ball beat him
there on time
but with the drop with the drop he's
safe
yeah the balls fumbled there by Murphy
Alvarez scores
Tucker delivers again and now it's Myers
Alvarez can move pretty well for a big
dude a big man he's picking him up and
putting them down you know if you're on
first base and that ball hits the Gap
you better be trying to score for him
especially if I hit it
[Applause]
Morel is behind the plate so far calling
a really good game I thought the Umpire
behind the plate could be a quite big
predictor of how this game goes with the
guy like Anderson who's gonna need to
nibble a little bit if the Umpire forces
him to come over the middle of the plate
this could get dangerous for him
gets a Chase there from Myers it's 1-1
do you think of that little kick from
Anderson before he delivers does that
distract hitters at all it doesn't
distract you too much the only thing
that it messes with is your timing
because you're trying to trying to
create your timing off of his motion
trying to see when he's going to be
releasing the ball and that little hitch
could throw you off just a little bit
runner's going and that is smoked it's a
foul ball look out Gary Pettis third
base coach for the Astros Tucker will
head back to second
heads up base running by Tucker right
there A lot of times pitchers will fall
into patterns
and they have to worry about that guy at
the plate and sometimes they forget
about you at second base
so Tucker being ready in that situation
he could have he could have got himself
an easy bag
[Music]
Tucker can move too
Dusty Baker told us this morning that's
a 30 30 guy we have in the six or
sometimes the seven hole in the lineup
foreign
Myers putting together a great at bat
right here talking to Dusty before the
game he's trying to determine how do you
how do you decide between Myers and
McCormick on who's going to be your
center field or you have two young guys
with the potential to be stars in this
game you're trying to keep them both hot
and today Myers got the call but I think
it's going to be a close race and
whoever's hot is going to get the
playing time right now McCormick hit the
injured list a little over a week and a
half ago with a hand issue that's when
Myers really took over the position now
he's off and running
RBI machine
since he was called up about a month ago
it's not quite Wally pip but once you
get that opportunity
you want to take advantage advantage of
it as a young player
time is called it's not fun for the
pitcher by the way kids Google Wally pip
if you need help
it's fair you're watching absolutely
there was a time I had to Google Wally
pills I'm not that old
it's a good story read and watch
Myers has done almost all of his damage
against fastballs in the major league so
far
see if that impacts this next pitch from
Anderson
here he comes he misses in
Myers would a short compact swing he
allows the ball to travel which would
help him after the two strike count
it'll help him in these situations
because he'll allow the ball to get deep
he's fine going the other way
he's not trying to hit the ball of the
yard he'll allow that just to happen
he homered on Monday off Kikuchi in this
series a three-run shot in the second
that made it five nothing
Houston had a big 11-2 win in game one
of the series
there's a swing and a miss Anderson's
second strikeout of the day
the grunt change up works every time
sell it
sold took that out of the Zack Greinke
book every time you would hear that big
grunt
you can just notice sit back a little
longer anytime you hear the big run
because he's trying to trick you
[Applause]
now marwin Gonzalez
minor league contract August 27th he was
let loose by Boston
he wouldn't know that around here from
no the fan reaction just now as he got
called to the play
huge hits in his Houston career he
played with the Astros from 2012 to 2018
almost 800 games
and the biggest home run in Astros
history
don't say so huh 2017 off Kenley Jansen
game two of the World Series in LA in LA
and Kenley was lights out at that point
in his career Untouchable basically
marwin unfazed
a do-it-all guy for Houston for many
years showing up to the ball fields with
sometimes eight gloves in his locker
wherever you want me in the lineup on
the fields he's ready to go with a smile
it reminds you of like a Chris Taylor in
La I mean you have a guy like that you
can deal with injuries much better with
other players on your team because as
soon as somebody goes down Marla can
step in and play that position and play
it well and I just fill in but actually
go out there and play the position well
yeah plus defense at many spots here
goes Tucker and Gonzalez takes off to
the Crawford boxes forget about it
the Astros grabbed the lead 3-2 off a
two-run shot from marwin Gonzalez
welcome back to Houston Marvin
it's a nice homecoming right there huh
oh that has to feel good
you back with your boys
having fun you know everybody in the
clubhouse already
and this ball gets a lot of play
Anderson's a guy who needs to be in the
corners he misses over the middle of the
play with this offense
off the bat he goes it feels good to be
back
that's the thing
Marvin really struggled with the Red Sox
77 games this season 202 just two home
runs but you return home to a place
you're comfortable with
he might be a big part of this team down
the stretch
[Applause]
thank you
no doubt about it off the bat of marwin
Gonzalez here's Maldonado base is empty
now here in the second with two down
Astros now up by a run
one of the huge benefits that Houston
has by being so deep with their
offerings is that it allows a player
like Maldonado who's not having the
strongest year offensively to be okay
and just continue to go out there
and work with your starting pitching
staff control the game and he calls an
amazing game you can't run on them it's
a great defensive catcher
and very valuable to this team
takes his first strike yeah and when you
look up at the lineup one through eight
you go okay Martin Maldonado does not
have to be Salvador Perez for us to be
successful
he'll have his days he'll have his
highlight days where he comes through in
a big situation
but when you're that deep it's literally
one through eight can beat you in any
situation I mean marma just hit that in
the eight hole you just had your
eight-hole hitter with the big home run
to give you the lead back and give her
Kitty a fresh start
and that's with bregman on the bench
Tyler Anderson tying his shoes and
getting ready to face the Astros lineup
for the second time
Altuve popped out to shortstop first
time around
I mean that's just not the guy you want
to walk
it's not the guy you want to walk in and
the last three guys that you faced
before that you had three balls over 100
miles an hour in a row and that's what
happens if you if you miss open the
middle
loud contact from the Astros this inning
Alvarez started it off with the single
past the shift even Correa with the
smash to third into the glove of Seeger
but without suvi what makes him so great
is that he's so unpredictable on when
he's going to be overly aggressive and
when he's not normally when you see a
guy swing at the first pitch of the game
that next at bat he would normally take
that first pitch
but Altuve knows that he assumed he was
going to get a fastball right there and
he was gonna try to jump on it jump on
it again
so for Anderson it's good that he went
with the off speed with the first pitch
better and move and then in on the hands
pop up and out of the inning
but the Astros put up three and they
snatched the lead from Seattle many
thanks to marwin Gonzalez hey marwin
Houston is home
[Music]
thank you
it is hard the other way got a chance
Fair ball yes indeed Kyle Seeker scores
and the Mariners have a 6'5 lead with a
big hit
and on the ground base hit
right field Corner JP walks on Mitch
strolls home
Kyle Seeger Chuck King
5-3 Seattle
one nothing Mariners ball game
[Applause]
the Mariners pitched back to back
shutouts
high drive right field
got big time carry Splash that baby
three-run armored Kyle singer 8-5 lead
for the Mariners
he drills this
drilled and crushed and this is gone
wonder what the vibe of the clubhouse
will be tonight
four nothing Mariners
our first YouTube poll is now closed
don't worry many more to go many ways to
get involved but who got the better of
the Astros Mariners deadline deal and
it's just been a battle back and forth
between Astros and Mariners fans and the
Mariners take it by 38 count that's what
you went with right that's what I went
with I think I think the fans made a
good call right yeah I think so so does
Abraham Taron I'm sure so does our next
guests joining us right now for our
YouTube shorts interview it's Chris
Flexin who's in the Mariners Dugout and
Chris we appreciate the time great to
have you on thanks for having me on guys
yeah of course and we also want to get
you involved on the poll too very easy
for you to answer this one because we
were asking everyone who got the better
of the Astros Mariners deal about a
month and change ago Ibraham tour looks
pretty good so far as your new teammate
what do you think yeah he's been
phenomenal you know he's really uh
holding together for us really helped us
out big time
Chris this is Chris young man I love
your story I love the grind that you
were able to go through from from
struggling a couple years before you
went over to Korea what adjustments were
you able to make that you were able to
bring back here with you
I'd say the biggest thing you know I
took over in Korea with me was really
trying to figure out how to trust myself
and continue to be confident and uh you
know going through New York and really
struggling you know really disrupted the
confidence but uh
you know trying to come in confident
this year and was able to get on a nice
little roll and have some fun along the
way does the multi-year deal that you're
able to get after the career deal kind
of ease some of the stress and allow you
just to go out there and do your thing
oh sure you know I mean that obviously
definitely helps
um
but at the end of the day you know it
comes down to just wanting to get out
there and compete and having the
opportunity to you know go out there and
try to make 30 starts and compete every
day to help us try to win ball games
Seeger France and Toro do up for the
Mariners in the third so Kyle Seeger
facing a 3-1 count from Jose urquide
he's about to deliver pitch number 50 of
his day
and it misses Lowe Ball Four lead off
walk for the Mariners here in the third
talking to Chris flexon and also YouTube
creators in the live game commentary
section you know what to do any
questions you have for Chris hook us up
we'll relay them over to him so let's
get your thoughts on Tyler Anderson not
just today but in general this season
since joining the ball Club another
trade edition how has he looked and
evaluate what he does on the mound for
us yeah he's a he's interesting you know
he comes from Over the Top comes from
the side you know throws a throws a four
pitch mix
um he's been great for us too I mean
he's a he's a competitor you know every
time he takes the ball he's out there
competing you know that's what uh that's
all you can ask for from these guys
I mean when you think about all the
pickups the Mariners have made not just
around the trade deadline but even
before the season started and Chris
you're going to be
part of that and we'll show more in just
a second here as it's Ty France facing a
1-0 count
there are a lot of players that came
around here we can look at the Bullpen
like Paul Seewald and
Sadler and
Drew steckenrider there are a ton of
players that maybe
had a journey some struggles in other
spots and then land here in Seattle and
have seen a ton of success in 2021
let's foul back just missed Thai Thai
France that's what I'm talking about
we'll show it on the screen flex and see
Walt the ravemen part of the story these
under the radar off-season acquisitions
what are the conversations like Chris
both when the Mariners are recruiting
players to join the team and sign like
you and then also once you get there
what do you think makes it special is
there some ingredient that has turned
the corner for so many players lately
I just think it's a great group of guys
um
you know we get along here pretty well
and uh you know it's a fun group we're
always having fun here and uh and
competing in in these ball games and uh
you know just like I said I mean earlier
for me like just given that opportunity
to go out and compete and it's been fun
it's awesome
and it's working the Mariners just three
games out of a playoff spot right now
seeker's on after the walk and then Ty
France facing a 1-2 count
and it's upstairs two and two all right
so here's our first question from a
YouTube Creator Cowboy Jeff Chris who
was your favorite pitcher growing up
oh so I was born in the Bay Area and I
was actually a huge fan of Matt Kane
he's in my book if you were wondering
actually I don't know he may not be but
uh he was a great pitcher he was a guy
who attacked the zone
three-pitch guy but he's gonna use his
fastball in and out and continue to
continue to just shove it down your
throat good change up good slider and
put the little curveball when needed and
you know we're gonna make sure we fact
check that too right Chris we got to
make sure that yeah just let me have my
moment yeah even if it's not true I'm on
the other end of that let's let's make
sure we fact check that no it's a no
it's it's a rare Miss there oh let's
pull up my terrible numbers then off of
them eight for 36. you held up all right
it's a couple doubles
tie France down on strikes there's one
gun in the third I only bring in another
question here this one from crash tag
hey Chris where's your favorite Stadium
to pitch at when on the road
I haven't hit all of them yet
um by the end of this year I think I'll
have three left I think I'm missing
Giants Toronto
and one other one but favorite one
home of course gotta go Boston was
pretty cool to pitch at that was my
first time this year and I I actually
had a lot of fun there it was pretty
chilling experience
yeah going with the class anyways
amazing yeah yeah that was that was
pretty awesome for me this year did you
find yourself in Fenway not coming in on
on on righties or going away from
Lefty's did you change the way you
pitched in Fenway because of the art uh
no actually that was actually one of my
better outings too yeah
don't let the park change but some guys
did right Chris a lot of guys did I mean
you had hitters who changed their
approach because of playing in Boston
yeah so they I mean it's definitely a
thing and you know that wall is sitting
there which looks like it's 250 feet
away from me yeah exactly it looks
really close
so I can play my mind games on you yeah
I I think uh I think Bogart's hit a
double Off the Wall off me and then um
uh Devers had a double Off the Wall too
so it was it was close but yeah I mean I
didn't change the laugh hitch I mean I
I was I try not to worry about that too
much
like you said it worked out for you yeah
yeah
seven Innings one run in that outing at
Fenway Park for Chris flexton talking to
us now he picked up the win in that one
it's two balls and two strikes to
Abraham Toro next question five point
vids Chris what's the best nickname
you've been given
oh do you have a nickname that everyone
uses
uh yeah here's the simple it's just Flex
yeah
plain and simple Flex I've always had
that oh that's right on top
get out of here
so Chris I'm looking at baseball
reference and big baby is your listed
nickname there yeah so New York gave me
that back in 2017 and that was
much heavier than I am now and had zero
facial hair and still have a baby face
but I got a little little fuzz coming on
right now but yeah that's all they had
they looked at me and said you look like
an overgrown baby and started calling me
big baby and then it kind of stuck so
but
growing out of that one
big man now Toro weekly to first and
that's handled by guriel he'll backtrack
and step on the back for out number two
well what's the story there because I
know there was some weight loss overseas
did you change the die out work the diet
workout plan how do you feel the way you
do now uh yeah I feel great now
um after my 2018 year going in 19 I'd
struggled with some injuries too and uh
you know it was kind of like a career
check type thing
um you know and for me I was it was time
to make a change and I I really
committed to it I went from 265 to down
to 2 30. wow uh that year from 18 into
19. and then in Korea I got as low as uh
215 and I came into this year about 2
15. and I feel better you know I feel
more agile on the mound and move better
and just be able to recover better and
just a lot more confidence yes God it's
different for every guy everybody has a
different playing weight that they need
to be in and it doesn't always mean
lighter is better yeah we have some guys
who need to be heavier some guys need to
be lighter but over the years you find
out what your happy zone is yeah and and
for me I I think lighter is better just
recovery wise and you know like I said I
struggle with some some injuries as well
that I think were weight related so
what's the key food that helped you out
also was there a key out in Korea that
you really loved
uh food out in Korea I'd say uh like
kimchi soup with some Ramen was my
favorite my favorite soup all time like
the food there was unbelievable
um I had a really good experience out
there and
really for the weight loss for me was
just committing to you know our goal and
uh you know really sticking to it trying
to eat just clean and you know a lot of
grilled chicken and some steak and a lot
of vegetables just really had to just
change the way I uh went about it paleo
action yeah and I heard the food out
there is incredible see why have you
been
never been I've always wanted to go yeah
if you get the chance I highly recommend
it I was in Seoul and uh you know I was
in the middle of Cova 2 so I didn't get
to explore too too much especially early
on
um but yeah if you ever get the chance
to go I highly recommend it I you know
once once this covered thing hopefully
blows over soon and then uh I'm gonna
try to head back out there to Korea and
go see everybody in like an off season
or something yeah we've got friends out
there and you can say hey what happened
here has really helped me in the big
leagues now right yeah absolutely yeah I
had a really good time over there we're
glad you're back here it looks like
you're having a great time I know it's
always a good sign when you're doing an
interview and your teammates are
throwing sunflower seeds at you so that
always tells me it's good chemistry
going on I think the guy JP was getting
me
[Laughter]
seems like that never gets old it's
always great yeah they got to get
creative yeah you got bubble gum yeah do
something else right I mean there's only
so much available in The Dugout tell the
guys to get creative in there switch it
up do something new
don't throw anything too dangerous so no
baseball bats nothing too dangerous and
nothing cold right yeah nothing cold
please yeah save that for walk-offs
here's turen's the one two and he stays
alive
Seekers on second at the lead off walk
then strike out ground ball out and
we're down to the number six hitter for
the Mariners hanging out for another
couple minutes here with Chris flexon
starting pitcher for the Seattle
Mariners hanging out in that dugout
what's the season been like I mean this
team is right in the thick of a playoff
race right now and it's a young Squad we
mentioned some fresh faces what's the
dynamic of the clubhouse and also just
the feelings here heading into the final
few weeks it's like you're playing in
the playoffs on a daily basis
yeah you know with the schedule we have
too you know a lot of a lot of teams
that were chasing as well
um no but it's exciting you know we're
we're eager to come to the park you know
we're we're looking to win ball games
Win series and uh you know fight for
that spot and uh you know it's a lot of
fun like you said it's a young group we
got some veteran guys here that are uh
you know holding it down at the top but
uh
it's it's primarily a lot of fun it's
fun competing with these guys as well
seems like it when I'm watching even
when I'm listening to you watch the game
it seems like you're in every at-bat
with your guys out there so how has it
been like everything that you'd imagine
to be in a playoff race with a group of
young guys with a few veteran guys that
kind of keep everybody keep everybody
cool calm and collected yeah I think I
think as a group I think we do a pretty
good job
um you know for some of us some of the
young guys and including myself I don't
I don't think I've ever really been part
of like a playoff push at the major
league level um
I was never really up there long enough
in in uh in New York for that any of
that but uh
yeah I mean it's just just keeping our
heads on straight and staying focused on
winning ball games and you know that's
that's all you can focus on grind out
ABS too like Louise Terrence sometimes
catcher sometimes first a little DH
today
fix contacts and it's gobbled up at
third by marwin throws across for the
out
Chris it was awesome talking to you it
makes me enjoyed it good luck the rest
of the way okay appreciate that take
care thank you Chris flexon hanging out
with us here in the third and who but
marwin Gonzalez making his first start
back with the Houston Astros has the
two-run home run in his pocket and a
nice play over at third Astros up by a
run mid three
foreign
catch Diaz to the backhand
not a natural outfielder but making a
fine play in left field there on the
slicing deep live ball of the bat of
Abraham Toro
that ball popped in the air long run for
bregman he's the only one that can get
there and he does in pal territory Alex
bregman a nice play to end the inning
strike three card runner on the go
that's a strike about throw mouth double
play
runner on the go the throw by stubs on
the money how about that Garrett Stubbs
popping out throwing a seed
[Applause]
Julie Uriel hits one high and deep down
the left field line and this ball is
gone
Yuli guriel La Pina cuts the lead in
half it's now a one-run game now Carlos
Correa swings and says what deep to
center field that Ball's gone
to back Jacks Julie guriel and Carlos
Correa and just like that the game is
tied at three two pitches two bombs wow
you're watching the MLB game of the week
Live on YouTube presented by YouTube
shorts watching create videos on YouTube
try shorts in the YouTube app on your
phone and we add to this unique viewing
experience don't forget to check out
YouTube's live game commentary we've
been mixing it in MLB channel you have
the Astros the Mariners channels select
group of YouTube creators and you can
view the live game commentary on
computer mobile device smart tv anywhere
you want to go there we're keeping an
eye on the discussion throughout the
game and that includes questions from
our YouTube creators hey I'm talking to
all of them right now get ready Lance
McCullers Jr is going to join us soon
first pitch swing and Michael Brantley
going to right center and Mitch haniger
runs it down for the first out but
mcculler is coming soon
he's going to be hanging out with us in
the fourth inning Brantley flies out and
we send it down to Brett Dolan hello
Brett hey guys I keep going back to our
pregame meeting with Scott service we
turned around and the Mariners were
taking infield and service said they do
this every day from infielders who play
every day this is the last game of a
road trip this is a day game following
the night game it's September the
Mariners are still taking infield and
they take a lot of pride in that but
guys I can't believe that's very common
among any other team and we're all
around the game a ton see why you played
double-digit Seasons In The Bigs did you
ever do that on a daily basis not often
but that's what tells me that these guys
first of all they're young and they're
willing to go out there and get this
work in they're out there on a mission
and they're going out there trying to
win games normally
after a loss like they had last night
you have the Day game after the night
game you want your guys resting normally
but Scott said that getting those guys
out there getting work on defense before
the game although they didn't hit
batting practice today getting their
guys up there it gets them ready for the
game and they come in they listen to
their music and they're ready to go
it's like a warm-up workout it's a
warm-up and you need guys which he
emphasized you need guys like Kyle
Seeger to buy in on it because the team
goes as Seeker goes so with them those
two guys able to work together to get
the best out of their guys that's
leadership on both ends
Brielle towards the middle and that's
gonna drop it's a base hit for Yulie
and it's a one ounce single for the
Astros here in the third
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean this Astros offense just
continues to put together good at Bass
continues to put the barrel on the ball
he said he wanted to go
a few hard steps
hey the 37 year old can really move
you can really take pitches now too it's
incredible to me one of the better
stories in terms of a hitting profile
suddenly evolving it suddenly such a
late age I mean Julie guriel was known
as a free swinger excellent contact man
but not a guy who would take walks and
all of a sudden he's taking a ton of
free passes this year and there was just
this natural progression of being around
some teammates that take pitches like
Carlos Correa and deciding you know what
I'll do what you guys are doing it's
almost as if he's always had it in the
Arsenal and he just decided at age 37
yeah I'm gonna spit out a few more
pitches he's always had it and he's a
guy that just covers so much of the
plate so I think earlier in your career
you know you can cover pitches outside
of the zone and it keeps you aggressive
but sometimes you have to know when to
pass the Baton and he's learning that
with this offense I mean you have
Alvarez right here behind you you'll If
he if they want to walk him he'll take
his walking he'll allow Alvarez to come
and drive him in
and pass the Baton is right when it
comes to this Astros lineup by the way
they're shifting Jordon Alvarez that's
why we have the shift tractor top right
of your screen show us where the
infielders are at all times
those little dots move along with the
players
cheers to see if that rule will ever get
changed the shift to shift
I think it will and I'm down for it at
this point two infielders on one side
two on the other we'll keep everyone on
the infield dirt
O2 cutting a Miss Albert on Alvarez
strikes out for the first time today I'm
a supporter of keeping the guys on the
dirt I'm okay if you want to shift if
you want to move around the dirt but
keeping floors on the infield and
outfielders in the Outfield
and if you want more production in the
game you want more action to happen I
feel like that's a pretty easy
straightforward way to get it done
yeah
remember the ship didn't work anyway
against Jordan for his base hit earlier
he eventually scored that was one inning
ago Astros put up three
Tucker with the RBI double two run Blast
for marwin Gonzalez in the eight hole
Marvin made a nice play at third base
and the last half inning
and here's the shortstop Correa
now two and up
talk about the Astros offense just a
little more although it's a runner on
first base two outs you think normally
that's a situation that's a low stress
inning but with this Astros offense you
never get a break and it always feels
like a situation to where somebody could
come through big and put a cricket
number on the board
and Tucker's been their hottest hater
he's on deck
Morales with the consistent strike zone
right there
not giving too much
force and Anderson over the plate
and you can tell Anderson may be a
little disturbed by that he wants that
call he needs that call
so right here just because of the 3-0
count
I don't expect I don't expect the
catcher to be set up down the middle I
mean this is a borderline pitch it's a
good pitch but it's a ball but you have
a lot of umpires that will call that
pitch and a 3-0 and 2-1 count
two very different situations to be in
I was right down Broadway
Empire crew today Gabe Morales calling
nice game behind the play you're right
very consistent so far today
and I'm a supporter of this I mean as a
hitter
that's a fan of the game I want strikes
to be strikes and balls to beat balls I
don't I don't think it should matter
who's on the mound or who's hitting
because back when I first came into the
league it had a lot to do with what
pitcher was on the mountain what what
player was at the plate on what the
strike zone would be you mean Tom glavin
got some calls he shouldn't have Greg
Maddox I'm not saying any men in the air
off the bat of Curry into center field
backing up kelnick he's got plenty of
room
and that will retire this side Carlos
Correa flies out nothing for the Astros
in the third but they're hanging on to a
3-2 lead as we head into the fourth
he just smokes it
forget about it
great baseball right there and that
one's gonna go that ball is crushed
is gonna do it
oh my
strike three
that was a great play
talked about his feelings skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
foreign
something like this is what they came
for
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
but today
um the greatest of all time thank you
[Applause]
May 191 Ricky Henderson epic classic
speech will always remember it so we
make up players all the time on YouTube
on a weekly basis which Hall of Famer
would you have loved to hear miked up
for a game Ricky Mays
Jackie babe you know we're putting up
big names when I only have to say one
part of the name this is actually one of
my favorite YouTube poll questions of
the Year get involved right now click
press do whatever you got to do touch
screen help us out with the poll answer
right now and we'll pay it off in a
little bit and also it's super relevant
see why because today is the Hall of
Fame induction ceremony in Cooperstown
look at the big names heading in being
enshrined Jeter Marvin Miller Ted
Simmons and Larry Walker that's all
happening today in Cooperstown right now
so good luck answering this YouTube poll
question I mean
the only reason I'm gonna get involved
on this one too the only reason that it
was a little easy for me is just based
on thinking deeper into the answer on
who you want to hear here's Christian
Javier by the way taking over for Jose
or Kitty I just like laughs so for me
it's easy to go with Ricky Henderson
because you know he is going to be
a walking comedian in The Dugout I want
to hear him Innings one through nine but
then there's the legends that you want
to know
go for it they're Legends and they're
great storytellers I've been fortunate
enough to personally personally know
Ricky I was with Oakland I talked to
Ricky all the time I personally know
Willie Mays when I would when I would go
to play the Giants when I was playing in
Arizona for some reason Willie Mays took
a liking to me and every time I went to
San Francisco he would take me to his
house
feed me show me all of his MVPs show me
his All-Stars show me his Gold Glove
trophies so I've had the opportunity to
talk to those guys so if I had to choose
one I'm choosing Jackie Robinson and I
want to hear those stories I want to
take that history in and and gain as
much knowledge as possible
I mean you definitely can't go wrong
and that makes sense hey I know a couple
of these guys so I'm gonna put them
aside because we've spoken before
because I know didn't you do some work
at one point in an off season or two
with Rod Carew I did I did I know Rod
Carew personally as well I'll name drop
for you
Jared kelnick struck out on three
pitches Christian Javier with four
strikes so far there's five that one is
socked center field off the bat of Tom
Murphy but Jake Myers is there
quickly two up and two down Javier
taking over the 24 year old
last pitched in Saturday's 10-4 loss at
San Diego gave up four runs in the
seventh inning including homers to
Machado
and will Myers
former YouTube player of the game
Christian Javier earlier this year we've
had the Astros a few times this season
Javier had a dominant performance I
believe it was against the Angels am I
right
truck crew
and Dusty got our kitty out of the game
he had the rough first inning but he was
able to dial in the end for the next two
innings for a guy who throws so many
strikes I think the only thing that got
him in trouble today was that for those
first pitches he was only three or 15
with first pitch strikes
and that that allowed his pitch count to
get up fairly quickly
it was right too it was against the
Angels five shutout Innings a while back
a few months ago
the sliders the money pitch for Javier
opposing hitters are just 110 against it
it's got
one of my favorite I guess terms for a
pitch the invisible action
which I'll let you explain more than me
in a moment that's off the bat
of Jose marmalejo Steve left field and
it's off the top of the wall
Here Comes Jake Myers to retrieve it
it's a two-out double for the Mariners
nine-hitter that one just kept floating
and floating and punched off the
Crawford boxes that left field wall here
in Houston and in Boston
it give it and it taketh away so I had a
lot of times to wear a low line drive
that I thought would be a home or a lot
of places would hit the wall here but
then you have balls like this those
those late I'm calling a Lazy Fly ball
to left field that's normally a routine
out but since it's only 3 15 down that
line it's able to hit the top of that
wall and turn into a double
flip the lineup card back to the lead
off man JP Crawford there it is you
mentioned Fenway the wall the monster
feels very close in left field sometimes
the Crawford boxes have the same story
it's not as imposing of course but
it's a good good spot to Target
especially if you're a righty pole
hitter
we just got a note from our amazing crew
the expected batting average on that
ball right there is 100. so I'm assuming
it's bringing those two stadiums into
play
and if that ball should be a hit or not
but if I hit that ball you better
believe I will not feel guilty or bad
about it
I'll take that double home with me
it took 11 homers home with you in this
ballpark in 33 games 362 average I
promised everyone in the beginning that
I'd mention it
and we're showing you the batting
average with two outs and running and
runners in scoring position for Crawford
it's among the Al's finest at 365.
your Ops in this park was over a
thousand
and regrettably I've never had the
opportunity to play here why not I
always wanted to play here when I would
come here as a visiting team I would
literally have to buy an entire section
for my family to come and watch the game
but I love the environment here I love
the stadium I enjoyed just the visual
that I got from this field it was a
great batter Zion Center feel I saw the
ball well I had a lot of success here
it's not too late it's not I was gonna
say let's run it back Cy in Houston they
call me I will pick up I promise
foreign
Park wow
take a chance on me just give me a shot
so if a YouTube Creator asks you where's
your favorite road ballpark
oh this is for misses to Crawford and a
two-out walk now two on for Seattle this
has to be it right based on the fact
that it's your hometown and you raked
here you know what sometimes it would be
slightly stressful coming home because
you want to see your family you want to
see everybody when you come in town but
but you also want to focus on your game
and try to and try to go out there and
have success but luckily I was a guy I
enjoyed that extra pressure I enjoyed
the pressure of having my family out
there and feeling like I had to do
something
the one thing your agency did well was
say Okay Astros moved to the American
League we're going to move Cy to the
American League too so he can at least
continue to hit in this ballpark more
frequently
there's a strike from Javier
it's number two hitter Mitch haniger
with two on for Seattle
Brett what else do you have for us well
I used to interview the post-game player
of the game and back in Chris's time we
would hand these players fifty dollars
cash I think I probably contributed
about 250 300 to him for all of his big
games here at Minute Maid Park I think
he was in the form of a gift card
maybe Best Buy or something like that
yeah
that old TV you have
Seattle putting himself in the position
to have a big inning right here very
much so Christian Javier laboring a bid
year
now facing the meaty part of the order
haniger fouls them back
to go back Scott so what you said
earlier talking about that invisible I
mean he's a high percentage fastball guy
but you have some guys in the league
they're able to throw a fastball has
that extra backspin on it it kind of
rides up through the zone to where as a
hitter you feel like you're about to put
the barrel on it but it'll just go right
over there
and you walk back to the Dugout confused
trying to figure out how did that just
happen
frustrating for those uppercut swings
manager
going after the invisible
thank you Mr Javier
good little clinic on the pitch that
makes Christian Javier so special along
with the slider as he escapes unscathed
mid four Astros up one
[Applause]
[Music]
middle the infield is back hoping to
turn a double play and conceding the
tying run Corners are in
Altuve drives one two left field Marco
looking at look at it that's gone a
walk-off slam Jose out to me
are you serious wow a walk-off Grand
Slam for a Jose Altuve wins it in the
bottom half of the 10th
Jose tries one deep to left field but
Castro looks up you've got to be kidding
me
he's done it again a three-run home run
for the second time this year against
maybe the most improbable comeback in
the major leagues this year unbelievable
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go
it is Creator Spotlight time we focus on
a YouTube content creator featured in
our live game commentary section today
we shine it on secret base over 1.1
million subscribers and Kofi spoke to us
on the pregame show he loves the Mets
and gave us a few Channel descriptions
like the Andy Chavez home run robbery
the 06 NLCS Game 7 at Shea Stadium go
subscribe to his channel and see more
from Kofi who is hanging out in the live
game commentary section as well we'll
get more from our YouTube creators
looking for some questions from them for
Lance McCullers Jr when he joins us
pretty soon right here on YouTube 3-2
Astros in front last game between these
two in the season series Tyler Anderson
matching up against Kyle Tucker and
pitching him in tight it's 1-0 and
here's the man himself Lance McCullers
Jr joining us for this half inning our
YouTube shorts interview Lance great to
talk to you I don't think we we've
chatted this year it's been a minute how
you doing yeah I'm doing well how are
you guys doing doing really well
watching Kyle Tucker in the sixth spot
look like a 2-3 hitter for anyone else
in that one might hit the top rails off
it goes it's twisting oh that's in
Fairgrounds
[Applause]
well you don't see that every day what a
way to start the inning
this year's launch angle what do you
think that number is going to look like
Lance uh that's going to be somewhere in
that 40 48 range
I'll get you that number from the
research crew in just a moment the first
person I ever saw hit went off these
beams was back in the playoffs of 2015
was Colby Rasmus
uh never no one had ever seen a ball be
hit here off the beams and then all of a
sudden uh take it for what you want but
after you know 15-16 they started
hitting them pretty often
I mean that was truly a moon shot that's
in a retractable roof that's a tougher
play than people gave it credit for for
haniger you're running full speed to the
line it looks like the ball almost
changes Direction
and as you're running full speed to the
line and it's there's no foul territory
over there all you see is the wall over
there as you're running full speed it's
very difficult to gauge when you need to
slow down and see that ball have that
effect of coming back
I think that's an impossible play
honestly I don't think I don't think
haniger could do much there we're
showing it again I mean it looked like
it completely changed directions for
Mitch haniger out there in the right
field corner
and then he grabs the baseball before it
could have potentially ended up in the
seat so it actually could have been a
ground rule double ends up being a lead
off triple for Kyle Tucker but
looks like they're going to review
things and make sure that it didn't hit
one of those rounds
wow
it doesn't look like it hit the railing
I I think it's one of those situations
if you're haniger you're just running so
fast and running out of room so fast
that you don't understand that the ball
just has a falling effect that it falls
to opposite direction similar to what a
catcher has to deal with on a very high
pop-up
also by the way if it hits the roof in
Fair territory
it's a fair ball right when it comes
back down if it's in foul ground it's a
foul ball but
I think this one's gonna stay put
it's under review at the moment that
normally only comes in play in stadiums
like Tampa you don't see that happen
here too much but mcculler says you've
seen it before right seen a couple times
Rafael Devers hit one up there off the
beam uh I think it was actually maybe
off Brad heacock I've seen uh Colby
Rasmus hit a couple up there uh you see
some hit up here like at the foul ground
uh right around Third Base some big high
pop up some varieties but the ones out
there in right field you got to get it
uh really Square uh you got to hit it
super high I don't know how high that
was but it's definitely a tough one to
hit over there ready for this launch
angle Lance
oh my goodness
oh he barreled it yeah he did
he barreled it straight up and it turned
into a triple still being reviewed right
now by the UMP [ __ ]
I'm just showing
all the replays we have for you
I I don't know if you change the
direction I think
that kind of thing he may have played it
into he said that a little bit they may
be reviewing if haniger if the fan
touched it oh right which could have
turned it into a ground roll double
so much to look at here it seems like
they're trying to review if it's a
double or a triple pretty much also why
we have a moment YouTube creators will
take your questions for Lance when we
get a result here all right what's the
move yeah he's safe and he's safe at
Third Base
all good
wow
this was the fan portion of it that
we're showing right now Lance just to
make sure so fan reaches over but it
lands in the glove of Mitch haniger
who's a whiff
good thing for the Astro side at least
but he didn't grab the baseball because
Kyle Tucker gets an extra base out of it
and it's a hit of course can't charge an
error against somebody's Fielder on that
one come on okay I didn't touch it yes
and Jake Myers will now dig in as we
hang out with Lance McCullers Jr now
let's have a normal conversation Lance's
Myers takes a pitch outside we have to
start with the slider and how it's
progressed and how it's been for you I
remember I called your game a couple
weeks ago on YouTube
and I was reading about how bran Strom
and Company and the pitching staff or
the pitching coaches said hey let's take
it easy on the slider this was in the
beginning of the Season let's see how it
looks
um now they're like yeah use it however
you'd like Lance this has become such a
weapon for you can you tell us the
progression
yeah I mean honestly it's something that
I've been wanting to throw for for a
couple years uh I just hadn't really you
know committed to it early uh in Camp in
order to get those reps you know last
year I felt uh in an ALCS gave up a
couple homers on some pitches that I
thought some good curveballs but it
really it really kind of made me feel
like I just needed to mix it up a little
bit especially to the righties
um with the way that my pitch groups
kind of look now so the slider
um you know kind of mirroring you know
off the two seam off the change up it
just it gives me the ability to attack
the Zone behind an account
um and even when I'm ahead you know 02
1-2 I don't really have to try to do too
much I can challenge guys in the zone
you know get get good results try to go
deeper into game so it's become a pitch
I feel very comfortable throwing
um you know Seattle they they're trying
to stack the lefties against me uh last
couple starts they don't want much to do
with the slider but
um you know it's been good uh it's been
a really really big weapon for me it's
helped me out this year a lot does the
slider have a name yet at for the
national audience because the curveball
is the Snapdragon right yeah me and Carl
McHugh we we had like a little joke back
in the day
um that was just what we called you know
kind of curveballs in general we kind of
yelled from The Dugout
um you know or like throw the Banger or
something like that so no no no official
name yet Colin throws a very similar
pitch
um it's absolutely disgusting you know
you guys see what he's doing with Tampa
Bay this year having a fantastic year so
when he they come here late late
September we'll have to have a formal
discussion and see what we can come up
with I like that man it's Chris Young
here man
you were a guy that when I was on the
opposite team I always loved being on
the team going against you and I was
curious just like as I have you now so
we might as well dig into it a little
bit
how familiar are you with your pitch
percentages and your numbers as you're
going throughout the season because we
would have scouter reports on you and we
would say Okay anytime this guy is in a
hitters count you're gonna get a
breaking ball so sell out for the
breaking ball and we would face you that
day
and in those situations you would throw
us all fastballs and you would continue
to flip-flop throughout the season to
keep us on our toes or keep us on our
heels sorry how aware you are of your
numbers and how much are you studying
that and knowing how the other team is
approaching you when you pitch yeah I
think you know in this day and age
especially there's just there's just so
much information for for both sides
right for pictures included
um you know you just try to you try to
you know keep the other team guessing
obviously there's there's no there's no
mystery you know especially if you're a
lefty I'm gonna throw you you're going
to throw a good amount of breaking balls
now if you're ready you know you're
going to get some sliders but there will
be games especially if I'm feeling good
with you know the change up I can throw
the change up you know 20 25 of the time
which definitely would throw a wrench uh
in a team's plan uh and and I've added
the cutter uh especially for lefties
kind of up to try to stretch that zone
out a little bit
marwin Gonzalez bounces out infield
drawn in now two down with Tucker at
third
you try to stretch those down a little
bit just because you know his Lefty you
know basically I'm on the front rail
with the two seam if you see it out over
the plate you're you're kind of
expecting more change up maybe break the
ball so the cutter up in a way right
around that you know 89-91 so there's
things that I try throughout the season
out of the cutter late last year felt
like I wasn't getting the uh the looks I
wanted from lefties and if I do face a
team you know and I feel like oh you
know this this is the game plan you know
we can you know we'll flip it the other
day I was facing um I was facing you
know Ty France he's been having a
fantastic season with with minutes form
position
um you know and attacked him with some
back door twos that felt like the slider
was something he was looking for Lance
does his homework that's for sure that's
a comebacker and a really nice recovery
from Tyler Anderson after the lead off
wacky triple from Kyle Tucker Lance
always a pleasure really fun talking to
you good luck the rest of the way we'll
talk soon okay all right guys thanks
thanks Les Lance McCullers Jr great
combo great game prepper and one of the
best on the Mounds it's 3-2 his Astros
leading it after four
come on chance whether he's rescuing
homeless animals through his foundation
working with at-risk young people
through Big Brothers Big Sisters Lance
McCullers Jr is driven by a phrase he's
driven by a thousand times there's a
bridge or a train track in Houston and
it's painted on there uh be someone and
it's just become a staple of Houston and
the core value of McCullers he now has a
be someone tattoo on his arm just below
the astronaut World Series Trophy and
Houston skyline that little area of my
arm
um is dedicated to the city of Houston
and just a daily reminder to try to be
your best self we have already hit our
hundred thousand dollar goal more often
than not when McCullers is giving back a
company that invented one of the most
unique baseball related products is
supporting him Dugout mugs makes
customized baseball bat drinking mugs
anytime that a mug of mine is bought
anytime a mug of one of our Affiliates
spot they're always donating back
proceeds to our foundation
thank you
hey the first Year tradition continues
we've given our viewers the power to
vote for which standout performer is
going to receive the U2 player of the
game Trophy and stay tuned later on
we'll have polling options and you'll be
able to help us hand out some Hardware
in the post game show immediately after
the contest comes to a close last week
the man on the mound for the Giants
Logan Webb did the trick and we'll do
that later let's finish up this poll
question one of my favorites on the
season which Hall of Famer would you
have loved to hear mic'd up in a game
Babe Ruth wins it
this was just an Ultimate Clash of four
Legends Ricky maze Jackie babe
you can't go wrong here first off you
can't go wrong I mean it's gonna be a
lot of history no matter who you're who
you're who you see out there but Babe
Ruth is going to have some great stories
Oh Yeah from back in the days back back
way back
it's in the dirt from Christian Javier
as we start off the fifth inning with
Seeger then France and Toro for Seattle
trailing by a run
Seeger with an infield single and a walk
his second time up he scored back in the
first
we also had four very different
personalities not that I know any of
them you do you don't know babe I don't
know babe we hear stories and I'm sure
on certain days babe was very
entertaining
and Ricky tells some great stories too
and the fact that you're talking in
third person for an entire conversation
doesn't get much better than that that's
really what sold it for me
Ricky would be narrating
and he would play to the YouTube crowd I
think too now see this is what Ricky
would do in this situation Ricky would
have stole that base Ricky would have
stole second and then Ricky would have
stole third as well if Ricky didn't go
deep
but Ricky probably would have went deep
that's what I was looking for
Seeger lays off the 2-1 it's three in
one
Kyle seeker's only hitting 212 but he's
up to 34 home runs this season 18 of
them in the second half of the year
foreign
and he walks for the second time in a
row statcast powered by Google Cloud
this is just going to help tell a very
simple story for us Kyle Seeger likes to
pull the baseball for his power 28 bold
home runs fourth most in Major League
Baseball you see the one opposite and
then a few to center field and the rest
are going to right
okay with that as a player because what
that tells me is that he knows what his
approach is he knows the caliber player
he is and he knows how he's going to be
the most successful at the plate and
some guys if they go up there trying to
hit the ball the other way on the if he
goes up there trying to hit singles down
the left field line he may lose that
strength so he's going to go out there
understand his strength and try to pull
the ball out the yard and it's turned
into a career power year this man at the
play type France is having a career
season offensively Brett Dolan what else
can you tell us well he got the opposite
Veil base sit back in the first inning
and Scott service told us before the
game he uses the whole field as good as
any right-handed hitter he has seen in
quite some time Cy brought up playing
for Tony Gwynn at San Diego State he got
one year with Tony before he passed away
Gwen used to give him a decal of a bat
to put on the back of his helmet every
time he had an opposite field base hit
you see his numbers what he has done
this year he's been fantastic in the
second half you wonder if that thought
that training from Tony Gwynn sticks
with him today and even when you go back
to a couple of years ago another Gwen
parallel when France got called up
mid-august from San Diego to San Diego
from El Paso he was hitting 399. nobody
had hit 400 in the PCL since 1933. I'm
sure he was glad to be in the big
leagues he probably would have wanted
one more hit and you think of the last
guy in the big leagues to chase 400
really it was Tony Gwynn in 94 didn't
get to finish his season either because
of the strike had to settle for 394. so
some fun parallels there with Tony Gwynn
and Ty France yeah that's great stuff
Brett and I actually called the AAA
All-Star game that year I was doing my
homework and I got wait I know that
there's some big time numbers in AAA
this season just a few years ago but I'm
like
see really hitting 399 who is this guy
and he was barely receiving any
attention
he's a guy
which one of one of my favorite types of
players is a big guy who just goes out
there and he's just trying to get hits
because what this tells me is that he's
gonna develop that power I mean he has
15 16 home runs but that power will
continue to rise but as long as he
continues to get his hits
he'll learn how to introduce that power
to the game and know when to go to that
when when to go to the well to try to
hit the ball out of the yard but
majority of time just taking your hit is
what your team needs
chasing some high cheese
he's whiffed a couple times today pretty
rare two strikeout day for Ty France he
did have the base hit in the first so
he's one for three Abraham Toro is one
for two and hits the first pitch the
other way left center field Myers
chasing it and he's
got the baseball
now heading back to First and in there
safely is Kyle Seeger Jake Myers with
the closing speed
wow what a catch what a great play and
normally to the naked eye you're
assuming that's the leftovers ball right
there but with all those little cutouts
that you have here at Minute Maid Park
you need one person to take charge Myers
probably caught that ball early
understood that he had the freedom to
not collide with the left fielder they
have that trust out there amongst
Outfitters and he trusts that he can go
out there and make that play he stumbled
too and then kind of disappeared on us
but he's got it that is a gutsy play
[Applause]
her statcast really helps us out
probability percentage chance on a ball
hit that way in terms of effects of
velocity launch angle how many times
does he get caught 10 of the time now he
stumbled you didn't dive or anything but
that is an elite catch out there in
center field
that shut out up the wall right there is
very scary when you're a center fielder
running directly at it
that ball was five feet to the right
it's probably a double off the wall
it went 106 feet Sprint speed at 29.5
very elite Mark for Jake Myers to cover
the ground
and this goes back to the discussion of
who's going to be your guy in center
field for the postseason it was Miles
Shaw for portions of this season he was
traded away to Cleveland it's Chaz
McCormick and Jake Myers out there
lately but manager Dusty Baker told us
this morning there's more experience for
Myers in Center
and so that could help make the
difference especially when you think
about postseason baseball and defense is
Amplified there
Dusty said that he has more experience
in center field he hits Lefty slightly
better McCormick has the edge on the
power but when you have two guys who are
hitting very comparable
I feel like in the playoff situation
you're gonna you're going to naturally
lean towards who's going to play the
better defense out there because when
the playoffs come around pitching in
defense as everybody knows is what wins
your games for you
now it's above average measures d
Ash shows best in baseball
clearly defense matters to this team
they have the formula
trying to get those 27 ounces fast as
possible and as efficient as possible on
a hop for Korea to step on the back of
the short way and retire the side after
the lead-off walk for Kyle Seeger some
good pitching and some strong defense in
center from the rookie mid-five Astros
still up 3-2
foreign
[Music]
this big party and here comes the man of
the hour Mark McGuire who is all for one
tonight his second event here in the
fourth sitting on 61. home runs
[Applause]
there it is
62. Touch first Mark you are the new
single season home run King
people cannot begin to imagine what
those two have been through in 1998 two
men
complete complete opposite backgrounds
joined in 1998 in the Roger Maris Chase
and it's Mark McGuire who gets to the
top of the Mountain Home Run number 62
and the Cardinals 140 45th game of the
year
[Music]
[Applause]
we're in the home fifth Astros lead it
3-2 Dusty Baker is inching closer and
closer to this exclusive Club he's at
1973 wins but you need 2 000 to get
through the bouncer see why I I don't
know much about it but this is a little
sneak peek at the 2000 win Club some
dress fancy some are in their game
uniforms but every conversation is
legendary everyone is legendary and
Dusty having a great season here at the
Astros I was so happy to see him get
another opportunity to manage at 72
years old he's not the norm in today's
game you don't normally see these
veteran guys still managing ball game
games and especially from coming from AJ
hinch to Dusty Baker those are two guys
that work very different ways Dusty
Baker is just the ultimate players
manager
it's been here forever he's done it for
a long time he earns the trust of his
players right away as soon as he walks
into the room if you're a player when
Dusty speaks you listen and at 72 years
old I'm happy to see him getting this
opportunity he's going to get the 2000
wins and I think he definitely belongs
in the Hall of Fame he wants a world
series title as a manager
still going after that Mark to solidify
the Hall of Fame case
fifth oldest manager in major league
history
and most wins without a World Series
there it is
1973 games incredible
he's had some pretty good teams as well
you managed a talented Washington
Nationals ball Club
Chicago Cubs back in the day right now
this Astros team is super strong in
every category
Altuve to lead off man Homer yesterday
2-1
is ripped left field does he have it on
back to back days he does
Jose altu Bay didn't Homer for about a
month
goes along yesterday and doubles up this
afternoon it's number 27 on the season
make it 4-2 Houston
never get a breakout touveau who is
known to pull the ball now he's going up
there every time knowing that he's
trying to pull the ball he's not the
same hitter that he was years ago trying
to hit the ball the other way he's
trying to expose his power you heard
Scott 27 home runs he's going up there
trying to do damage he was able to able
to drive it out the yard right there
probably 316 feet I would say
that's all he needed
that is only a home run in one stadium
in the major leagues I'm not just saying
that there's statistics to back that up
yeah that's not a homer in Boston that
could potentially be a single in Boston
believe it or not if the left fielder
knows how to play it off the wall
but it's not about how far it goes
just a matter that it gets up out of
there first row Crawford boxes Homer for
Altuve and now a roller for Abraham Toro
to clean up
first out in the fifth
back to Dusty Baker for a moment
who's loving this I'd say veteran group
there's been a Corps there for a while
for Houston
five teams managed by Dusty in 24
seasons
three-time manager of the year ahead of
really good looking San Francisco Giants
team that made it to the World Series
and he's just been not only a smooth
experienced voice in the clubhouse but
really and
a strong Ambassador for the ball Club
Julie guriel takes the 1-0 it's 2-0 he's
one of those managers to where as a
player you're able to gain that trust
right away
because you know that he's going to tell
you exactly how it is if you're not his
guy he's going to let you know hey you
have to earn this spot or if you are his
guy he's gonna look out for you and he's
going to put you out there no matter
what if you have some struggles he's
going to stick with you because he
understands that for us to win you have
to go I mean clearly he's mannered some
very good ball clubs been to the
postseason multiple times the World
Series I think at that point is just a
coincidence it doesn't mean that you
can't manage in this situation it's just
pure coincidence that it's just really
hard to win a World Series and
everything has to work out and everybody
has to be hot at the right time and if
that doesn't happen you don't win the
World Series just part of the game
four pitch based on balls for Yuli
guriel the number three hitter is on
board with one out in the fifth and this
copyrighted telecast is presented by
authority of the office of the
commissioner of baseball and may not be
reproduced or re-transmitted in any form
in the accounts and descriptions of this
game may not be disseminated with that
Express written consent
now you're Don Alvarez
one out one on and a run in for the
Astros on the Altuve Homer here in the
fifth I mentioned Ambassador for Dusty 2
for this team because they had to
weather the storm of the sign stealing
scandal from a couple years ago and you
know he had to deal with a lot of those
questions when he wasn't here Alvarez
is a foul ball
hooked to the right side another hard
hit baseball off the bat of the Astros
cleanup hitter but Dusty is just a guy
who had the right answers at the right
time for this team to kind of help them
get through things and even last year we
went over some of the adversity that
they dealt with
they were one win away from the World
Series
running the ship that's a bad year in
Houston
this team has been on some run for a
long time now
and I'm very curious to see
what Dusty decides to do after this year
what the Astros decide to do with Dusty
Baker how many more years will he get
the opportunity to manage or
will he walk away how many years does he
want to manage still and he says he
wants to keep rolling
great ball Club to lead Runners going
pitch is hit hard off the bat of Alvarez
right to haniger and he's coming for
first and he's gonna miss him Ty France
looks like didn't nail the tag down on
Julie guriel so just one out put a good
try there by haniger who has an
excellent arm in right field
great job by guriel keeping his head on
this will be you're trying to steal that
base but he peeked in at the right time
right here you'll see you see he peeks
he sees that fly ball oh I gotta get
back and luckily the throw was just a
little bit up the Baseline
was able to get back just a bait the
attack barely
look at this avoidance by Uli guriel
touch me
that uniform means a good cleaning now
that's what you want yeah that's what
you want as a player you got to get
dirty
there's a lot of discussion earlier in
the live game commentary about the
Mariners uniforms Sports gaming Universe
said these Mariners all jerseys have to
be one of my all-time favorites in MLB
makes me think of Griffey Jr and then
when they had some success later on Andy
Rulo said that's the magic of the
Northwest green jerseys I love them
is that teal
for getting fancy it's just classic I
love it yeah it does remind you of
Griffith though that's a great point
reminds me of the kid out there with his
hat backwards
coolest customer in the big leagues for
what
almost a couple decades
in smyrna's ball Club trying to get back
to the playoffs for the first time since
2001. they're three games away from a
playoff spot that second Wild Card seed
entering the day
Houston at 81 and 57 six and a half
games up now on Second Place Seattle in
the division
Tyler Anderson at 73 pitches so you're
going to pick on Julie again nope he's
going home
and it's a foul ball so hopefully I
don't jinx Anderson right here but he's
a guy that goes a little bit against the
grain of today's game which is something
that odorizzi ran into in yesterday's
game and that third time around the
lineup
Ops doesn't go up against him he's able
to get through the road get through the
lineup three times and guys consistently
be around the same numbers as opposed to
order is yesterday which there was a
little conflict after the game because
he was pulled after only 60 something
pitches or whatever it was it wasn't a
lot of pitches he felt like he's 66
pitches yeah five innings two runs and
he said I'm glad we won if not I'd be
the subject of Wayne basically said 66
pitches through five there's not much
else to say I was trying to infer that
he should have pitched longer in that
one he's a veteran on the mound but he
voiced his opinion strongly after the
game and eventually he chatted with the
front office and with the coaching staff
to kind of clear things up but these are
kind of like playoff games right now
it's the last game of the season between
these two and look at Carlos Correa
Connect into right field
to add single Astros in business here
now in the fifth with Kyle Tucker coming
up he's two for two today with a double
and a triple
[Applause]
just a quick visit I see they do have
somebody up in the bullpen
you said I don't want to jinx I don't
want to jinx them I thought about not
saying it because every time you say
something it comes back and fights you
but because of his track record because
of the numbers saying that he can't get
through the lineup three times that's
how he's earned this opportunity to get
out of trouble right here
and still try to find a way to get him
get himself a win
sometimes Carlos Correa has struggled to
stay on the field you can see this is
just his second season at 120 plus games
but when he's on the field he's been
super productive last year was a down
season but it was a shortened season
many stars struggled in limited time but
perfect here to have a platform season
for Carlos Correa
and it's not just what he does at the
plate he is having a super year on
defense too and the metrics back that up
there's Casey Sadler getting hot
big test for Tyler Anderson he's only
had 76 pitches
and he's given the M's at least five
innings in each start that he's made
since joining the ball Club via trade
the only dangerous part here with Tucker
is that he's hit the ball hard two times
he's sitting with a double and a triple
already obviously he sees Anderson
really well so that's the only thing
that could potentially change this
decision when when your service trying
to decide if I'm going to allow him to
face him in this situation or not
you have your Lefty Lefty matchup
2-0
close to hitting the hands of Kyle
Tucker
and a lot of times Lefty Lefty match up
or righty righty match up matters when
you're when you're trying to make this
decision but you also have to look at
the previous at-bats and understand how
this guy is seeing the ball off of this
picture
yeah both balls were 100 plus miles an
hour off the bat for Tucker although
that happens all the time now 3-0
and Anderson knows he knows that stat
you just said he may not know the exact
number but he knows it was two missiles
off of this guy's baton and I can't just
come across the middle of the plate
right here I need to nibble even in this
3-0 count I'm saying he's not trying to
throw a cookie down the middle you'll
you'll still see him catcher set up on
the corner right here trying to execute
a pitch hope that he expands his Zone a
little bit he's one of the best control
artists in the game the 3-0
is a little up and I don't think I mean
I know he wanted that call but I don't
think he
needs yeah and here comes Scott service
I don't think he
needs to deal with Kyle Tucker with the
production that he's had against him
sink or he just missed up according to
Gabe Morales
Here Comes Scott service do you like
this call though and I asked that
because and there's the pitch from
statcast
Jake Myers is on Deck Jake Myers though
for two a couple strikeouts swinging I
thought Anderson would hang around here
to try and get himself out of the inning
this is actually going to be the first
time in 27 starts for Tyler Anderson
that he doesn't go at least five innings
so he is clearly frustrated Sadler's
gonna try and clean up this mess in the
fifth
[Music]
oh my God
foreign
all right
boys
[Music]
now it's gonna be a good time
[Applause]
[Music]
Google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
Google cloud is the official Cloud
technology of Major League Baseball and
statcast powered by Google Cloud had to
do a lot of work here and follow this
baseball from Kyle Tucker
not to the seats to the roof
five degrees on the launch angle
it was in the air for 6.8 seconds at one
point we're like is it coming back that
hurts you have seven seconds to to make
the play right there and Mitch haniger
just couldn't find it in right field now
the bases are loaded for Houston key
spot in the game Tyler Anderson removed
for Casey Sadler who you can see has
been lights out
in his 30 appearances this year era a
few Shades below one on the season one
of those
gem fines for the front office
he's really turned his career around
this is his fourth organization since
2018 and by far his best season of his
career
although this guy is statistically the
best in the league and this is the guy
that you would bring into a situation
because although it's the fifth inning
this could be the inning that determines
who wins and loses this game depending
on if he gets out of here but if you're
Jake Myers I think you're okay seeing
Sadler right here after two strikeouts
in the first couple of bats against
Anderson you're looking for a different
look and Myers does take off gives that
one a ride to deep center field but
kelnick is there so it all worked out
for Scott's Service pulls the plug on
Tyler Anderson goes with his super
strong Bullpen but the Astros do add a
little Insurance here in the fifth
number 27 for number 27. that's what
Healy six said in the live game
commentary watching it all globally
today on YouTube Astros going for the
sweep doubling up the M's for two
here
[Applause]
[Music]
Thai friends
[Music]
swinging a high fly ball into right
field playable haniger comes in it's
Toro drifting out the Mariners second
baseman is unable to make oh he made the
catch he lost it it popped in the air
like a snowball and then he made the
catch again
one out Bases Loaded pitch number eight
to Toro
s this drill
Ed
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ball game today between the Mariners and
Astros and we're checking out the
notable free agent class of shortstops
coming up in the off season ABI Baez
Carlos Correa Corey Seeger Marcus Simeon
is playing second base for the Blue Jays
but he can certainly handle shortstop
and then Trevor's story on this list
Francisco Lindor would have been a free
agent but the Mets lock him up to a
long-term deal right before the season
started so our next poll question has to
do with that after this pitch here from
Christian Javier misses down to Jared
kelnick who made the last out in the
last half inning which free agent
shortstop is most likely on the Move
changing teams this off season Baez
Correa show you more in a sec as that's
a little bloop shot over third and it's
a Seeing Eye Single for Jared kelnick to
start the sixth
back to the poll question for everyone
start voting please get the answer from
see why what he thinks in a moment
who's most likely on the Move bias
Correa Seeger's story I'm gonna go wild
here and say and it's not an option
we're looking for most likely but I
think all four change teams in the off
season what about you
I think all four could definitely change
teams I mean I saw some recent
statements from Korea to where you know
he doesn't know if he's going to be here
or not if I had to choose one guy that
will be moving I'm assuming Seeger will
be moving around with the signing of
Trey Turner with so many versatile guys
and that Dodgers offense
I don't think the dogs are gonna go over
the top to try to keep secret and I
think there's another team that'd be
willing to pay up to get him to leave La
you think he's the most likely even more
so than Trevor's story who's on the
Rockies who's going to be a free agent I
think there's a better chance that he
latches back with the team that he's
playing with right now yeah I think
Seeger's my guy okay I'll stick with my
gut on this one although they both can
be moved
but I still think Seeger's the guy
that's the most likely to you
well he's gonna have some money to spend
too maybe they land one of these
shortstops let me run it back uh-oh some
of the drama that Baez has had to answer
you I'm sorry I'm sorry everybody bias
is probably gonna make a move unless he
finds a way to rekindle rekindle that
relationship
over there in New York and I'm going to
give a thumbs down to him returning
to the Mets this off season O2 misses up
and in
to Tom Murphy number eight hitter
that's why I'm looking at that list I'm
going it's actually a good question
because I think they all could be moving
so which one is most likely if you're
banking on one it's definitely not going
to be with the same ball club that he's
with right now what's your pick
vote and we'll show the results later
foreign
could be next for Houston after Javier
short day for Jose urquidi he's still
coming off the shoulder injury in the
middle of the Season he missed a good
chunk of time and Katie making just his
second start off the IL only going three
Innings 70 pitches now Javier taking
over for some long work having a weapon
like Javier who's able to come in he can
throw a lot of fastballs to come in and
relieve rakiti and give you some quality
innings in the middle of the game that's
so valuable for that Bullpen and
allowing the guys at the back end to
stay in their in their you know in the
role that you want to see them in
yeah do it all guy in the flex position
he can start too he's made nine starts
big swing and Miss pitcher on the mount
Christian Javier
too squirrely so far today two hits
three strikeouts a couple walks last
year finished in third place and Al
Rookie of the Year voting
[Music]
well Brett the Astros can swing the bat
and they don't miss much they play great
defense and the pitching just hasn't
skipped a beat even though there's no
more coal there's no more Verlander
they just pump out arms in this
organization well there's no doubt about
it and I think Brent strong is the guy
that we know about maybe we don't give
him the full credit on what he has done
since 2015. you talk about where the
Astros rank third in the majors and
earned run average since 2015 second and
whip first in opponents Ops the Dodgers
lead all the categories but there's a
big difference between pitching and
Chavez Ravine and Minute Maid Park you
mentioned Cole gone a couple of years
ago ver later hasn't been a factor but
Brent strong finds a way to get it done
his philosophy of high fastballs
curveball usage use all the quadrants
it's been very successful and he came
here with Jeff luno and AJ hinch he's
still here with James click and Dusty
Baker and that's obviously for a reason
he's a big part of what they do pitching
wise he's a staple in this organization
he was into pitching up in the zone
before it was cool
back when it was you know sinkers down
slide her down get those ground balls
here's a Fly ball off the bat of
marmalejos in foul territory is guriel
for the catch and the first half here in
this sixth but Brent Strom always
believed in using the Arsenal up in the
zone and it really is in Vogue nowadays
and you have some teams that just
understand the picture philosophy I mean
you see the Astros in the White Sox
Granite they have really good pitchers
but they have a plan and an approach on
how to attack an offense and it's proven
to be to to work
they're going to work with
their next man on the mount Brooks
Rayleigh Dusty Baker takes the ball from
Christian Javier two on for Seattle here
in the sixth Rayleigh coming in
[Applause]
right now the Mariners looking for the
tie they would take a fly ball they
would love a base hit into the Gap and
they could win it with Junior speed
everybody's going to be straight away
Edgar sprays it all over all right ball
hit right center I can definitely go
first to third left Center first to
third left field line is a little softer
if it stays down there I can go from
first to home it's my field so I know
home field so here it is he
[Applause]
I turn around you know to see where
Junior was
[Applause]
he was flying now he's seen him run that
fast before
[Applause]
my wife is I didn't know you could run
that fast
I ain't supposed to show that all the
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
this rivalry is certainly heating up but
it's been lopsided for the last few
seasons Astros 36 wins just 11 losses
against the Mariners since the start of
2019. it's the second most dominance
we've seen from One Division opponent
against another in the last few years
only Cleveland pouncing on the Tigers
has shown us more dominance and that
continues this week at least but like I
mentioned Seattle's played much better
against them this season really go back
to 2019. the Astros were 18-1 that year
against Seattle last year seven and
three and this year 11-7 at the moment
thinking sweep today leading 4-2 with
Brooks Raley the 33 year old left-hander
taking over for Dusty Baker's Houston
Astros ball club going up against Scott
service and a surging Seattle team that
they hope has their best years ahead of
them one of the top Farm systems in the
sport as well and just three games away
from a playoff spot top of the order JP
Crawford two on one out
here in the visiting sixth
Israelis numbers
not pretty
era in the five and a half range
and he last pitched in San Diego on
Sunday picked up the last out of the
sixth inning which actually was a caught
stealing so only four tosses in that one
it's another kitchen sink guy cutter
slider Sinker curve four seamer
he could pretty much throw everything
but he still gets in trouble with that
cutter and sinker with hitters hitting
over 300 off of those pitches
Okay so
with kelnick reaching on the single
Murphy walking and number nine hitter
Jose marmalejos the last man out
if Cy was managing
this is always a tough situation for me
so as marmolejo is coming to the plate
I'm assuming you gotta runner on first
and second no outs you're hitting the
nine hole you're scuffling a little bit
is this a situation that you would put a
bunt down and normally you would say yes
and I think
you know the manager has to be thinking
about that but the problem is that he
hasn't done it at all this year and in
his pro career he's never had a bunt
that was the only thing I'm thinking is
JP Crawford strikes out nice pitch from
Raley and tipped into the glove but
marmolejos has done some serious damage
in the minor leagues hasn't converted
really much into the majors but I was
thinking has he bunted much in his life
and the answer is no that's why I
personally believe you need to continue
to work on that through the minor
leagues even if you're the star on your
minor league team you don't know what
your role is going to be when you get
caught up to the big leagues just
because you're in the 3-4-5 hole in
double A doesn't necessarily mean when
you get to the big leagues and you're in
a big league lineup that you're going to
be that middle of the order guy
and as a manager I think Scott is hoping
that if he gets in that situation he can
he can call it because you don't want to
wasting that bad and call upon if a guy
has never bunted before but you would be
nice to be able to have that weapon
you're down by two runs with a guy
scuffing with the bat to be able to get
those Runner Runners over and give
Crawford a different mindset as he's
going to the plate with the runner on
third base with less than two outs
but as a whole the Mariners don't bun I
mean they have eight sack bunts this
season which is the fourth fewest in the
majors
and I know bunting is a lost art but at
some times when I'm watching a game
it just seems like the right play and
got and teams rarely go to it anymore so
the Mariners did it last night in the
top of the 10th
didn't work out for Dylan Moore
Mariners come up empty
in that inning and then the Astros
walked him off
but you're right I mean Seattle and
Houston are in the bottom four in Bunsen
baseball this year
and something else that could go into
that decision is how well they normally
hit with runners in scoring position
bounces out
look at bricks Brooks rally come in and
pick up two outs strikeout ground ball
and the Seattle Mariners strand two here
in the sixth and still have just two
from that first inning
[Music]
you can bet at this time in the game
that Mr Kyle is extremely aware of the
fact that there's a major zero in that
hit column
played by Tim and Eddie he chose anyways
it was caught on the line so two men are
gone
ball is short so Daniel Longfield
[Applause]
here's the drama right there you see
that zero no hits for the Mets
third ball one hopper to the shortstop
So Daniel to First and power is two outs
away from a No-No 2-2 pitch
strike three
one two pitched
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
listen to MLB's podcasts to hear the
latest analysis from insiders across the
league and exclusive in-depth interviews
with baseball's biggest stars subscribe
now at mlb.com podcasts the MLB Ballpark
app will complete your next visit to the
ballpark buy and manage game tickets
redeem offers access exclusive content
and much more download the ballpark app
today
it's hot outside in Houston but guess
what this ballpark has a lid on it
and it helps
orbit is very thankful for the climate
control as you can see
he's one of my favorites by the way
I'm saying there's still a heavy sweat
happening under under that soup right
now
Orbit's like the new school Philly
fanatic for me similar personality but
has some
modern tricks so does Joe Smith he's
been fooling hitters for years he's 37
years old has one of those unique arm
angles that gives you a completely
different look out of the bullpen he's
pitched better with Seattle since moving
over in that highly publicized trade
that featured Abraham Toro and Kendall
graveman
Smith now against his former ball Club
here in Houston in the sixth
like you said he's another guy who has
benefited from the change of scenery
with over seven ERA with Houston able to
come over to Seattle get a fresh start
and have an era in the low twos
he's always had that funky arm angle
Sinker slider guy he's a guy whose
Slaughter was always very effective in
the past but this year it's been getting
hit a little bit and that's what caused
the issues with his era over with
Houston
patching up with his former teammate
marwin Gonzalez
marwin homered in the second
when you're coming from a sidearm angle
with that slider you literally need that
ball for Marlin you literally need that
ball to start well off the plate to come
back over the middle if it starts on the
outside corner by the time it gets to
you that's in off the plate
and it's always touch up the gauge that
as a hitter on where this ball needs to
start when you have a reliever coming in
with a completely different arm angle
from the guy you put you faced before
you faced him two for seven
it wasn't comfortable though no
didn't look like marwin was comfy there
Skype
and caught
one out in the sixth it's Kyle Riley the
rookie with the microphone today for us
on YouTube
my uncle has a normally large hands I
still think it is it's the biggest World
Series ring ever made Florida Marlins
really was it 03 or O2 so I went and
they didn't have anything that fit them
and it was a 17
and a half
his sausage fingers
go on Story Time with gal all day long
on YouTube
sir's uncle's gonna appreciate the TV
time that he got right there about his
sausage fingers it will Live Forever on
YouTube
I need to see these fingers
we need a photo of the fingers post a
video
Martin Maldonado thinking about a bunt
for Cy but pulls back
I like it when you're hitting you try to
get creative up there when you're
scuffing a little bit he's he can peek
down now that third base line and he
sees how far back Seeger is and he says
if I just get it by the pitcher
I think even I can beat this beat this
out
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's kind of like a punt and bear hand
Joe Smith throw did he stay on the bag
yes Ty France did for out number two
who said pictures aren't athletes that
was a very athletic play right there by
Joe Smith able to bounce off the mound
right away bare hand this ball he
understood the runner that was running
get his feet up under him he didn't have
to rush it and make a solid throw to
first base
it's bare-handed
he called it a snatch kind of look at
this crap if you have Altuve running
right there it forces him to rush a
little more
it's a lot tough for play play to make
when you have the catcher running you
know you have a little extra time to get
your feet up under your plant and make a
strong throw to first
Jose altuvet time homered in the fifth
he had gone 134 at bats without a home
run
July 30th up until yesterday number 26.
today number 27.
Smith is staying right on the corners
right there
this is a sizzling bat
two in his last two home releasing his
prior 31.
good swings lately from Jose
for Jose to do what we call that in the
baseball Community is a trophy take a
trophy take is when you pretty much just
stand up there take a ball right down
the middle you had no intention of
swinging but that tells you how
uncomfortable it could be
to face Joe Smith Reach For One
and kelnick makes the call
and the side is retired three up three
down Joe Smith taking over in the sixth
inning and doing his job Mariners need
to figure out some offense 4-2 after six
[Music]
heart is palpitating
[Music]
Frozen for a strike and Johnson Payne I
think thought that was end of ending
yeah
he'll be hearing at the Empire's room
left in the game today
pulled down the line and caught and
she's in the Dodger jersey one gone this
ball is hooking back there oh no foul
okay you can catch it
[Music]
[Applause]
can Santana get it out yes that went off
of his foot and at one point was 62 feet
in the air
Olay
3-2 he's running
swung on and missed throw to Second and
they he missed him a nice move by Mateo
he was out the ball Pito to watch this
move you talk about athleticism huh how
does he avoid that tag Now You See Me
Now you don't a little magic out there
[Music]
thank you
this is this is my chance I have I have
an audience now if Cody Jinks hears this
I'm going to your concert
this off season so
it's always found me
it's not like he's my walk-up song or
anything
let's go Cody is definitely going to
hear that and those two are gonna hang
out in the off season I'm calling it
thank you Cal he's miked up today and
we're finishing up this whole question
on YouTube which free agent shortstop is
likely on the move this off season a lot
of Astros fans are watching and voting
clearly and thinking that Carlos Correa
is on his way to another ball Club 35 he
takes it
listen there's a lot of shortstops on
there who do you think gets the biggest
contract out of those guys
that's another question
before this season started I would have
said Kyle's brother Corey
it's one and one
to the Elder Seeger Cory's dealt with
some injuries this year but man he was a
superstar in the postseason last year
World Series MVP did he win nlcm NLCS
MVP too he did
big cut and a miss from big bro Kyle
it's one and two
Kyle's been with the same franchise his
entire career
former third round pick out of North
Carolina back in 2009 and he's up there
in the franchise ranks 11 Seasons with
the ball club and there's a club option
for Seeger in 2022
for 15 million bucks saying there's no
doubt on that club option no doubt
getting picked up I mean he's he's your
guy
so durable
he can play full season he's not getting
injured he's reliable
and to be reliable has a cost
he's down on strikes
[Music]
Here Comes Ty France
[Music]
I thought
he told me the Mariners were going over
on the odds courtesy of bet MGM it was
Monty they had two runs in the first
but they need to reach four to beat
these odds
they're gonna see another pitcher maybe
that does the trick give me Garcia one
of the newer members of this Bullpen
we'll head to the Mounds and take over
for the Astros in a moment
she arrives
again I can remember talking to players
in other teams before they talk about
how players to get jri does you saw a
lot of cases of j.ritis you know if
somebody woke up with a stiff neck and
somebody else had a fever or a cough or
something like that they didn't want to
be out there big guys I mean Hall of
Fame guys they didn't want to play they
took their days off when J.R was
pitching
at six eight and over 250 pounds Jr was
in fact an imposing presence on the
mound
and there was something else just a bit
scary about J.R Richard but he is so
strong he's got the he's got the most
ferocious handshake uh that I've ever
encountered he's just got Mammoth hands
as a PR guy at the time we had him had
him pose for a picture I think holding
eight or nine Baseballs in one hand he
has eight he put nine balls in his hand
thinking he went like that and we took
the picture made a poster out of it once
we saw that everybody tried to see how
many balls they could hold in their hand
and I think I could hold three or four I
don't think I could hold seven golf
balls in my hand
I had two pitches
fast and faster at my best I can throw
it through a car wash and never get it
wet
[Applause]
[Music]
go behind the scenes watch exclusive
interviews check out the latest mic'd up
content and more on the Mariners YouTube
channel subscribe today at youtube.com
Mariners and MLB Original season 2 is
Live on YouTube with new episodes every
week so your favorite players and learn
more about the game you love on
youtube.com MLB
it's where you are right now
MLB YouTube channel for the game of the
week
Astros and Mariners for the last time in
2021 in the regular season first and
second place ball clubs in the AL West
next up out of the bullpen for Dusty
Baker 31 year old yimi Garcia first
pitch fouled back by Ty France we saw
yimi yesterday start the sixth inning
gave up a go-ahead home run to Kyle
Seeger so they say you know what
we'll let Brooks Raley strike out Seeger
now you take over for four five and six
against this Mariners ball Club there's
the numbers for Garcia on the year he's
14 fastball velocity has boosted up from
last year which was a career year
and even in 21 he's starting to open up
his Arsenal quite a bit he's become
pretty much a four or five pitch guy
with the four seamer the slider the
curve and then he's introduced the
change up in the Sinker as well to try
to mix it up and be able to keep guys a
little more off balance
boom Ty France fouled one off his leg
he's always been an extreme Fly ball guy
seeing High home runs besides 2020
you know he's been giving up the long
ball and that's all and that's got him
in trouble
how does that feel
oh it never hits the shin guard shin
guards right there he found a way to hit
right above it
and he's back in there I'm balling two
strikes
[Applause]
thank you and here we go you see you
would think they make the shin guard two
inches taller
but if you did he would just hit it off
of his knee you just continue to move it
up on where you're going to hit the ball
you have that protection there for good
reason because it protects your foot it
protects your ankle it protects your
shin
you just can't predict where that ball
is going to go more Shin coverage please
you see him limping out of the box
if he gets a ground ball right here
we're going to see him limp down the
line I'm assuming
and I've been to yard on Alvarez over
the weekend he came back quickly though
that was a weird we'll hit it off his
back knee I was watching that game I
know that hurt I thought he would be out
for a little bit me too that is
Smash down the line Ty France is gonna
head to Second easily with a stand-up
double
are they still feeling that the double
always makes it feel a little better
though run it out
that was absolutely cranked a great
great piece of hidden just line the line
guy he gets two strikes down on him he
doesn't panic stays with his approach he
can go right field line he can pull down
left field line
we've been harping on him all game but
he deserves he's a great hitter
Jimmy just entered
and they're having a chat on the mound
here's haniger though
pulling one down the line his first a b
he went to right field with a single
[Applause]
France hitting the ball all over the
yard you can't shift them you can't
protect the line you have to play
straight up and it opens up holes for
him
to be able to get those hits and he hits
fastballs of course but what makes him
stand out is the secondary stuff he can
handle as well
[Music]
it's Phil Mayton
another new member of the Astros Bullpen
from around the trade deadline in that
mile straw deal with Cleveland
that was the one portion of the ball
club that needed work for Houston first
half of the Season there was Bullpen
issues
I'll enter yimi Garcia and Kendall
graveman and Phil Mayton
problem somewhat solved I would say
Houston always does a good job in
bringing in those complimentary pieces
they're one of the teams that has kept
their core together for quite a while I
mean these guys that are on the field
right now are the same guys that I was
playing against a few years ago and
that's not common in today's game guys
move around all the time but Houston has
been able to keep their core together
and then bring in a few pieces from time
to time when they need them
they could change this off season a
little bit
with Korea potentially leaving Verlander
potentially leaving
but they've been able to deal with that
too I mean Derek Cole is now the star in
New York City for the Yankees and
yet still this is a top five starting
pitching era team when they lost coal
and then then I saw the news of losing
Verlander
Toro a little
squibber and the play is not in time off
the bag is guriel
and safe at first is toro France moves
up to Third
Correa couldn't make the play lone man
on the left side of the infield
that's Marlin right there oh yeah marwin
that's what happens with this ship
sometimes guys get out of position and
that's a ball that's normally right at
Korea I mean routine play directly at
him but with that shift forces marwin to
move to the side he rushes to get his
feet up under him you see him fall after
the throw the ball was pulling that way
that he was falling and and it pulls
guriel off the back
it's a hit for Abraham Torio Runners on
the corners with just one down in the
seventh
here's turen's
I like keeping my Shortstop on that side
if he's all alone on the left side and
keeping him in familiar territory I know
that most baseballs are heading more
towards the middle and that's why the
shift is on but Marvin could handle a
ball up the Middle with less ground to
cover exactly and that's something that
you would see with San Diego a lot to
where when they do their shift Machado
will go over to the other side you keep
your shortstop in position because he
should have the most range you're
assuming so you keep him over there by
himself and allow him to make those
plays and that's why Korea has the top
five wins above replacement Mark kind of
an overall stat to measure how effective
he's been top five in the AL
okay so defense didn't work out for
Houston here against Toro but statcast
powered by Google Cloud showing us Jake
Myers figuring out where that baseball
was going to end up and making a catch
that happens just 10 of the time 106
feet covered by the rookie center
fielder to Rob Toro back in the fifth
and there's a big strikeout picked up by
Garcia terens goes down and there's two
away
two beautiful sinkers down and in right
there on the corner where you feel like
you're about to hit it at the last
second it drops right under your bat
that's perfect location
hitting that lower right quadrant
sinking right under his barrel and 96
never hurts
for a guy to be able to gain two miles
an hour in a year on this fastball it
changes your dynamic as a pitcher the
strategy here it's like a playoff game I
mean this is a huge matchup against the
team looking up at Houston in the
standings so now it's Phil Mayton time
in the seventh with two outs and two on
for Seattle
[Music]
and with the team just one game back the
September Battle Cry that had come
straight out of the stands was feeling
more real than ever somebody had a
banner it was out in center field that
said refuse to lose and Luke said I saw
I saw a sign said refused to lose I like
that and I mean that was it
gives the mirrors a standing ovation I
remember that even if we were losing
we felt that we can come back in any
game
every day there was a new hero
[Applause]
ES
fans are losing their minds people were
starting to really recognize something
really special is happening here
that time there's no loud Stadium
every day was louder and louder and
louder the kingdom became one of the
characters in the story it was like
being on the inside of a popcorn popper
every single night
[Music]
let's go back in time Edgar Martinez the
Hall of Famer off Jack McDowell ALDS 95
game five
I was a talented Seattle Team grippy
come on down he was gliding around those
bases right there
that's one of the most memorable plays
ever right there yeah super stall ball
Club but they've never been to the World
Series it's the longest active pennant
drought at 45 Seasons the only active
MLB franchise to never make it to the
fall classic and see the other streaks
are for teams that have been to the
World Series
so they have that and the
post-seasonless drought which goes back
to 2001 but they're working on that
Phil Mayton numbers with Cleveland and
then Houston this year era in the four
and a half range going up against Jared
kelnick the rookie goes after the first
pitch and puts it in the air Myers
tracking back similar spot where he made
a catch this time he's gonna have to
play it off the wall and the Mariners
are going to tie up this game
Jared kelnick has himself a 2 RBI double
one pitch from Phil Mayton turns into a
4-4 contest
it's a great piece of hitting for
killing it to be ready for that first
pitch breaking ball right there I'm
assuming there was something in The
Scouting Report a lot of times right
before you're at that you go to your
hitting coach you look at the scout
report you know what he throws in
different situations and right here to
him for him to be able to take that
breaking ball the other way it tells me
that he was ready for it he was wait
wait willing to sit back and wait on it
and drive it the other way
it's a great piece of hitting
enters in Toro standing we are tied
I think now is the time to mention that
the Seattle Mariners are 29 and 17 in
one run games
most one-run wins in baseball this year
Houston in those games are 16 and 16.
and the two words that have been echoed
nationally about the Mariners
that I don't care a ton about run
differential
at this point in the year
yes run differential matters it tells
you a little bit about your team
but going into the last month of the
season
as the team you're not worried about
that you can't worry about that anymore
it doesn't matter how we got here all
that matters is that we're here and
these games that we have coming up
doesn't matter that we're minus 45 run
differential like I understand that's
that's a big deal and it means a lot to
how they got to the situation and it
speaks a lot to their bullpen
but when you're playing the game you're
not worried about any of that right now
you just have to be in this position
a lot of late offense and a shutdown
Bullpen for Seattle
part of that one run record this is the
career pinch hitting line for Jake
Bowers 7 for 33.
this season in his last 17 games he's 10
for 30.
so in 2007 there was an Arizona
Diamondbacks team that won the AL West
for the negative 20 for the NLS I should
say with a negative 20 run differential
the Mariners in the AL West this year
are at minus 56. I know a little bit
about about that team yeah I don't think
I played on that team I think you did
and with that team in 2007 I distinctly
remember we depended on our Bullpen so
much we had really good starting
pitching with Brandon Webb
but we needed our Bullpen back into the
bullpen guy Valverde was our closer we
knew we could play seven inning games
Brandon Lyon was out there if we could
lead after seven or be closed after
seven we felt good that we could win the
game and the Mariners are in that
position now
you led that 07 team with 32 home runs
Jared kelnick with the big swing on the
first pitch that he saw from Phil Mayton
ties up the game fresh contest let's
stretch
come join the team be a part of the
Astros buddies club kids 12 and under
can sign up to be a member of the club
where members get access to exclusive
activities a backpack socks and an
Astros hat all for only 25 dollars
show your Astros Pride at home school
and at the Ballpark
get your membership today by visiting
astros.com forward slash Buddies
looking for fun with the fam this summer
look no further than Minute Maid Park
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this ball ripped down the right side
he's gonna be waved around
goes with it
get your tickets now at astros.com
tickets
[Applause]
[Music]
the postseason race is on MLB.TV now
only 26.99 catch all the action live or
on demand plus MLB Big Innings
restrictions apply visit MLB.TV for
details coming off the seventh inning
stretch for
we gave out some peanuts and Cracker
Jacks it was fun
tradition here in the Astros Booth
anyway worst run differential among
teams with a 500 record Seattle's now
500. they're nine games over at -56
meanwhile the Astros are plus 176 third
best in Major League Baseball well guess
what
Seattle is in a fight for a playoff spot
they're not there but they're three
games out and to me that also gives
extra credit to their Skipper Scott
service in a manager of the Year race in
the American League managing tight ball
games and turning up with victories that
certainly helped and he calls it forget
run differential fun differential that's
a great Point by him in those close
games for a manager you have to make a
lot of calls a lot of clutch calls and
without those one run games the Mariners
are in a completely different position
you're not even talking about the
Mariners right now we're probably not
even doing their game but being able to
win those close games gives the team an
extra boost of confidence to where you
never you feel like you're never out of
the game and you're ready to play and
you're and you're being very competitive
and it's great for them
Anthony musavich in the game
and then firing a strike Brantley guriel
Alvarez due up for Houston in the home
seven
brantley's hit list today
so we stayed we said earlier the keys to
the game you have to stay within
Striking Distance they're there fleeted
air
that's up to that Bullpen naseevich has
it bounce off I think he's pitching hand
and turned into an infield knock for
Michael Brantley you'll see if he's okay
that's a hit and
how's that left hand
see where it got him
see where it got him
he's rubbing the ball down I think he's
standing the game his body language
looked like he was hurting yeah quite a
bit right there
he was in between trying to use his
glove and use his hand and sometimes
you'll see pictures just try to get out
of the way
and let their defense behind them make
that play but he got his feet kind of
tied up to where
he felt something on maybe his ankle or
his legs to where he was limping right
there
just an awkward play very awkward
looks like he's doing all right though
always go glove
Johan Ramirez is there just in case
and he just told him he can chill a
little bit
[Music]
looks like Diego Castillo and the
Marines bull plane he's also just
starting to stretch the arm out and get
ready
great Point by Cowboy Jeff the Astros
always seem to be in close games in
these games of the week yeah Jeff and we
thank them for that it's been fun guriel
on the ground and this could be too
there's one Crawford fires to First In
Time
and suddenly the left hand feels even
better absolutely and Hampton's been
used a lot this season he leads the
Mariners on appearances this season
so he's a Dependable guy
he knows when the game starts he's going
to find his way into that lineup
on his way to the mound now the races
Brantley and takes care of guriel
sweet turn there by JP Crawford
off the feed from Toro
and here comes Jordan Alvarez after one
more look from really hurry up
sevick
he's still limping a bit
Savage 26 years old
facing Jordan Alvarez
Lefty on Lefty although I will say
Alvarez
has no problem with southpaws in his
young career he has no problem with him
he's able to stay Square
and he lifts one in the right center
he's hanging up there for haniger to put
him away it's work lead off hit for
Brantley but Muriel bounces into a
double play Alvarez flies out and the
Savage heads back to the Dugout after
seven 4-4
[Music]
foreign
I'm from Seattle Washington and I'm 13
years old I was born with hypoplastic
left heart syndrome so half a heart I've
had 22 procedures and four open heart
surgeries I like baseball shoes I have
two sisters one older one younger and
one younger brother
I like to customize shoes collect
sneakers and I'm trying to start up a
business where I customize shoes it's
easy being his dad he's blown me out of
the water on numerous occasions just by
what he's done and what he's chosen to
do I I love watching him play because I
I understand
what it what it takes for him to
to be on the field overcoming
hypoplastic love heart syndrome it's
limited me to stuff that I can do and I
still try to do it but
and I'm playing baseball so that's
pretty good I'm Tyson and I'm a member
of the first class of the hometown nine
[Music]
[Applause]
another great one the MLB game of the
week Live on YouTube is presented by
YouTube shorts watch and create videos
on YouTube try shorts in the YouTube app
on your phone check out the Astros
YouTube page for Insider content
including behind the scenes takes from
your favorite Astros players coaches
broadcasters and more visit youtube.com
Astros to subscribe to the channel today
Scott Braun Chris Young Brett Dolan
ball game's still fresh 4-4 we're in the
eighth
Kendall graveman against his former ball
Club the 30 year olds having a career
season ERA at 169 on the year I remember
when he was a starting pitcher
especially in say 2 2015 soft tosser
he's pitching low 90s 91-ish now the
Sinker averages about 96 miles an hour
is transformed into a serious weapon out
of the bullpen for Houston what a
transformation what a transformation
that is I mean he's a guy when he's on
the mountain now you're going up there
knowing that he's going to give you a
sinker but he has he has the big depth
on it to where even if you're looking at
it it's a struggle to get to
traded at the deadline
from Seattle to Houston
Astros needed Bullpen helped this was
their big Target
here he is pitching in the eighth
scoreless eighth last night and 13
pitches to get the job done
marmalejos in the nine spot
doubled in the fourth
takes a strike to start off the eighth
right there the first pitch Slaughter
you're just keeping everybody honest
make sure he's not trying to jump ship
or sneak attack you right out the gate
show the soda slider first
then go to your bread and butter which
is that sinker
have fun with that
what I did like about seeing the
personal side of players when he did get
traded from Seattle I mean he was
clearly very emotional about it you know
you realize the type of bond
that these guys have with each other
's not pleased with the called strike
three
Frozen
borderline pitch right there
what's your call it's been a great
strike zone all day I mean that's a
borderline pitch
I'm mad at him I'm mad at the call if
I'm hitting but once I go in to the you
know video room or whatever it may be
after the game to look at that pitch
what I'm going to say is that you
haven't caught that all day that's what
I'm going to say that sounds good I'm
not happy about it that's through the
vacated left side it's a one out Knock
for JP Crawford
yeah it was a money pitch there for
Kendall Graven to pick up the first out
but now dealing with a speedy runner on
first in Crawford
JP Crawford being able to beat the ship
right there he keeps finding a way to
get on base make things happen
especially against the Astros and in
clutch moments
we're up to haniger
and his base hit was off the third base
bag in the first he ended up scoring
it's a two run first inning for Seattle
first five batters went four for five in
the game
and they cooled off for a while
and picked things back up in the seventh
with two more to tie things up thanks to
a Jared kelnick double
hey
pitch right there painting down the zone
panager known to make the adjustment
this season to be a lot more aggressive
in the box so he was up there ready to
make a move but that fast that Sinker is
just so sneaky he couldn't pull the
trigger on it
manager does pull the trigger this time
and it's in the shallow Wright's gonna
fall
on to second is the throw in time
oh Kyle Tucker duked us a bit
on a Little Blooper that ends up being a
force out at second
and that's a play where nobody did
anything wrong
Crawford did exactly what he was
supposed to do on the bases when you're
right there in between first and second
and you watch that ball in the air
there's no real way for you to tell if
Tucker's gonna be able to lay out and
make that play or if he's going to let
it drop and Tucker did the right thing
but not giving up on the ball showing
that he was coming after it but when the
ball drops having the wherewithal to
keep his bearings and make a strong 30
second base
and a great snag battle Tuesday right
there
until they have to turn into a little
first baseman right there
wow
two down in the eighth
great call right there great play ball
too big getting stretched out
money throw
so it's a fielder's choice for Mitch
haniger exactly that's what I was gonna
say that's the most unfortunate part
about that is that you get a floater's
choice
when I bought it
could be a single if nobody was on base
yeah no hit for haniger making him now
one for five on the day
Kyle Seeger's turn
Tucker
special ball player
tools Galore
he's got power in the bat he can run
clearly Can field his position
young ball player and he still somewhat
does it under the radar like when you
think of the Astros you don't Kyle
Tucker is not the first person that you
think of but when you come to the game
and see his skill set see what he's able
to do on both sides of the ball
you realize how valuable he is to this
team
that wouldn't look like it missed the
mark on the change up from grebeman
and strike one all right the zone is
opening it up a little bit late in the
game
that's not their secret waited for a
tick
[Applause]
ER froze on that one like here we go
Raven's like where was that well where
was the pitch before
not that that matters but
Kyle Seeker take your base
that was low that's low that's a ball I
mean Maldonado is
an excellent framer behind the plate
look where his glove ends up right in
the middle of the zone
it's a better move right there yeah
Tai France climbs in a single a double
and two strikeouts
Craven being very effective to
right-handed hitters
throughout the season giving up zero
extra base hits to them
I don't know if that if that bothers Ty
France at all because he's not up there
trying to hit an extra base hit he's up
there trying to keep the line moving
he'll take a slap the other way be very
happy with it
and where is that baseball Maldonado
can't find it here and both Runners will
move up
graveman had to help him out for a
second
so right here
you have France in a 2-0 count
who's been hot all year you have Toro on
Deck
who has killed you since the trade
happened
this is a situation where it's a tough
call to make for Dusty Baker for Graven
for Maldonado
you got the right handwriting matchup
that you would normally would want right
here
wild pitch from graveman yeah pick your
poison I mean
France has the hit tool
and he pulls one third base side
and this will do it
all right wasn't the smoothest day for
Kendall Craven but no runs come across
for Seattle they strand two in scoring
position and this game remains tied at
four
foreign
[Music]
last year was not the same part of my
rehab and my motivation to really get
back to this team was being able to hear
those fans and be able to experience
Minute Maid back to the roof one more
time the noise the atmosphere it's
unmatched from every day and they
support us they're out there screaming
it just makes us want to play better as
a team I think we have the best fancy in
baseball the main reason what we play
because of them
this is one of the most community-minded
teams that I've ever been on yeah and
and these guys are very aware that they
are part of the community I had a long
conversation with a lot of guys that
donated water
um and I had a real long conversation
with you know with bregman that always
steps up you know you got out two Bay
and you got Korea and all these guys
always step up for the community you
know I thought that was pretty
you know pretty cool
[Applause]
let's do it
locked up at four a piece we're in the
home eighth and we're looking at the
teams to reach the LCS in four straight
post Seasons the Houston Astros have
done it and taken a couple pendants and
one championship
Sonic Cardinals and the Braves in the
90s the Yankees had that dominant run
and the extra actually the last team to
win back-to-back World Series it was
three in a row
back in that time period and then you
look at that Oakland team in the 70s so
it doesn't happen often to get that
consistent success that we've seen from
this Houston franchise and also I just
think about how difficult it is to win
back-to-back World Series titles we
haven't seen it in over 20 years at this
point I think the team that won last
year certainly still has a good shot Los
Angeles Dodgers fighting for an NL West
and we'll get to them in a moment Diego
Castillo is about to make his 50th
appearance of the Season he started the
year on Tampa Bay he was one of their
better relievers closing out games and
you know the race they're like no we
don't have emotions with our moves not
at all I mean right here you have a true
slider monster I mean this guy Diego
Castillo he's a majority slider guy I
mean you're going to see a slider almost
seven percent of the time and then he
uses the Sinker off of that
so to be able to have that much
confidence in your slider to where guys
know that they're going to get and they
still can't hit it
that tells you the depth that he has on
it and I'm assuming we're going to see
quite a bit of it this inning
there it is to Carlos Correa
that was a short slider too I almost had
a cutter action to it just enough to get
you off the barrel
but he can throw strikes with it as well
so different versions of the slider
making it like multiple pitches that one
is connected it's a fastball Correa
likes it and he's on with a lead off hit
in the eighth
this is what the Astros do they're going
to keep pressure on you Correa has been
having great at bats as of late
consistently putting great at Bass
together
coming through late in the game you
could create in the seventh eighth ninth
inning
it's almost a guarantee that he's going
to come through right now
makes a good spot looks over to the
Dugout too to pump them up
Castillo disappointed
what he's disappointed in right there is
the shift yeah what he saw was the
ground ball to second base he feels like
somebody's supposed to be right there
and it messes with some pictures I
played with some guys who would rather
not have the shift at all and just
take their medicine if they gave up a
legit hit in their eyes
but they couldn't stand that one time
that you hit the ball right at where
somebody should be
and it gives up a base hit especially
late in the game on someone in the front
office or coaching staff has to put
together a highlight reel of all the
times that it helps and say look
watch this
Kyle Tucker has been on base in five of
his last six at bats he is smoking hot
right now back to Korea for just a
second three of his hits over a hundred
then that one right there was 99 point
and some change right the first three
times up you're saying was oh 99 earlier
in the game oh 99. let's
let's give him four balls at 100 miles
an hour
two of them were outs two of them were
singles
[Applause]
who strikes on Kyle Tucker
since coming off the covet IL
13 games up until today and then the
numbers look even more video game-ish
because he's two for two double triple
walk
and in the last two weeks this is the
guy you want up if you're Houston
a lot of situations when you come off
the IL and you put up numbers like that
it's almost like a huge trade
acquisition late in the season
Big Time him and bragman coming back
around the same time but look at him
gone fishing I mean yeah that slider
right there is just nasty I mean he he
sees that ball out of his hand as that
same Sinker and he attacks it like it is
a sinker
but then it
gotta guess you're picking and choosing
and he got Sinker and he was wrong
Jake Myers is hitless in three trips
today
look at that line for the rookie
about a month of baseball
over 300 with the batting average for
the center fielder
what I like about Castillo he's staying
down in the zone he's trying to stay
away from damage pitches when you leave
something up in the zone in a yard like
this with that short left field porch it
doesn't take much to get it out of there
so he's staying down down and down
try to get his ground ball try to get a
double play
[Applause]
down for a swing and a miss
that's one of those pitches on TV it's
like oh why'd you just stay back on it
and end the other way that pitch right
there is painted on the corner down and
Away there's no chance in a 1-0 count
that you're able to drive that ball
that's a pitch you have two strikes on
you and you choke down and pepper it the
other way
Castillo has just recently back from the
injured list
right shoulder inflammation
he did appear yesterday in the eighth
inning scoreless inning took him 20
pitches
and his below's down a little bit
he's averaging 94 last year was average
in 96.
hey everyone's a strike
and he gets that strike call because
he's so close to the Zone on every
single pitch
to where the Umpire is
Loki guessing in these situations yeah I
was close enough they're all close they
all look like strikes they all look just
off the plate I'm trying to and it's so
hard to to gauge that with the naked eye
it was in the zone 90 of the way and
then tailed off at the end
Myers with an underwater swing and he
goes down
and that was an impressive sequence
right there working that slider down in
the way Sinker down and in
all around the plate the entire time
[Applause]
and able to expand late with two strikes
that was beautiful
I honestly think anybody would have
struck out with that sequence right
there yeah that was a special sequence
put together by Diego Castillo
[Applause]
pulling the rookie Myers now dealing
with the veteran marwin Gonzalez
who homered in the second
similar swing there that we saw from
Myers if you're looking at these swings
these guys are so uncomfortable and
they're not able to pick up that spin so
they see it popping out of his hand and
they're literally guessing is this the
Sinker or the slider Alex bragman's gone
I wouldn't have swung at that will you
see me yesterday against Paul Seawall
yeah we'll see if marwin can keep this
inning going
has had some really clutch hits and
Astros franchise history
he's received by far the best Ovation
with us being here inside the ballpark
multiple times hearing the crowd go nuts
for marwin Gonzalez
I mean you took that one but it's in the
zone yeah when you take it it rides out
through the Zone when you swing at it it
drops
there was a time where you had Castillo
when he was in Tampa Castillo and
Alvarado in the same Bullpen talk about
a righty Lefty combo right there for you
you know movement off the charts from
both of them
it's pulled foul by Gonzalez
back in the second inning
Arwin Gonzalez
the Crawford boxes
400 feet
his first home run back with the Astros
and his third on the season
this place has to feel like home for
them
he's in an O2 hole
tempting and Diego Castillo is feeling
himself right now oh he's feeling
himself and these next these next couple
pitches he's going to continue to try to
expand the Zone I don't see him giving
marwin anything to hit these next couple
pitches he's gonna either go slider down
and in on him or he can he can sneak
that Sinker away on him as well
foreign
but I haven't seen a pitch middle of
this entire inning I mean he's staying
out of trouble he's staying down in the
zone I'm about to see the Sinker right
here
it's going to sink her away
[Applause]
and his job to stay alive just waiting
for a mistake that has not happened yet
that was a great piece of hitting by
marwin I know it's a foul ball but that
that wins him another pitch
this ball takes off off the plate
Marlin's able to cover that but that
tells me that he may have a little
somewhere that he can expose him on the
inside right here if you can cover that
we're gonna go now we're gonna go in and
see if you can cover both sides
oh wow what an inning from Diego
Castillo you can't cover both produces
the whiff after the Correa single Tucker
Myers Gonzalez
foolish
[Music]
and Diego Castillo brought his A-Plus
stuff into the eighth inning and it's
the Mariners turn in the ninth coming up
oh don't come near me hey dude I'm mic'd
up right what you better give me some of
these clips
I know that's what I'm trying to do
nope
I want him to hit line drives you have
to make a read you have to play it back
go get it
this is more realistic you know this is
what I like
what kind of shoes you're working with
JP Jane's hard on
oh new Adidas hey what are those called
these yeah I don't know I found them on
eBay
80 bucks use steel
thank you
that one
[Music]
we go to the ninth inning tied at four
the Mariners though have not hit a home
run today you may lose this bet as far
as percentage of runs scored on home
runs the Giants lead everybody at 51
percent Mariners were second last week
they're now third 49 percent of the runs
come with the long ball and Scott and Cy
and games they don't home are 13 and 26
so we'll see if they can change that or
whether they're headed towards Extra
Innings again another area that they
normally have great success with yeah
great Point thanks Brett I mean
yesterday we saw extras in Seattle not
coming out on top
the Mariners in close late situations
have been clutch all year they're hoping
it rides them into a postseason
good luck with Ryan Presley
the all-star
with the era south of two
ninth inning action Toro Terence kelnick
there's a strike to Abraham Toro who
actually is two for three with a home
run and a double off the Astros reliever
that Homer came in torio's Mariners
debut on July 27th It's also two for
four today
he's swinging the bat well
depressing with a lot of success
a little fastball slider curve mix
look what happened to Ryan Presley last
night
Michael Brantley bows the ball off of
Presley in the dugout
look at him we got drilled in The Dugout
limping a bit he didn't look like he was
too happy about that oh he pitched in
the game yesterday in the ninth trailing
3-2 oh wow
buries one in the dirt Toro goes after
it and strikeout number one for Presley
here in the ninth but yesterday
Toro got him for a double and then
Terence brought Toro home with the RBI
single this time he says
go for that
his two secondary pitches that are
standout
you got two strikes on you go ahead and
take a gamble expand the zone go ahead
and Spike one he wants to make sure not
to hang this pitch right here so you go
ahead and bury it in the dirt see if you
can get the fish to bite
it's Terrence who got to him for the RBI
hit yesterday
he's over three with a walk
a long swing
slatter right there on the corner
that's the dominant [ __ ] for Ryan
Presley
batter's just 132 off the slider with
one extra base hit this year
and he connects Right Center Fields Luis
Terence with a hit in back-to-back days
off Ryan Presley
this game is tied at four because Jared
kelnick contributed a double that went a
long way statcast powered by Google
Cloud
387 feet it's a homer in two ballparks
this one is off the tall wall in left
Center and scores two the rookie coming
through and the Mariners in yet another
close game and looking to come through
in another clutch situation potentially
try to get that player of the game if
you can come through here and get that
go ahead RBI last man Off the Bench
Dylan Moore is in the game as a pinch
Runner Terence is out
we're now in the DH spot he's on first
the only disadvantage I would say to the
ship right here you see Korea pulled
over to the right side of second base
only disadvantage of the shift here it's
very tough a lot of times to get that
double play ball that you need to get
out of the inning
so the trade-off is you cover more
ground on the right side but the
disadvantages may not be able to get
that double play you may have to get two
guys to get out right here Impressions
trying to get rid of the runner
trying to keep them close for sure
only allowed two stolen bases in the
last couple seasons
Dusty's group going for a sweep today
what a game kelnick takes it down
more at first base 18 for 22 in stolen
bases so Presley has good reason to be
concerned about him over there at first
you got to keep him close
try to keep the double play in order as
much as you can
and hope that they have to earn two hits
to get this Runner to score
with the quick slide step right there
it's going to be tough for him to get
this backed up
and with Maldonado behind the dish
sometimes sometimes what will happen
here when you're focusing so much on
that run on first base
is that you don't focus on the hitter as
much as you need to you get behind the
count
and you leave a ball over the middle of
the plate you're killing it who's
feeling good today
yeah single double
oh back pick try
and more is safe
Maldonado
thank you
well Yadi Molina impersonation right
there
okay to scoop that ball make a perfect
throw to first base
some catchers will go down to a knee
right there and just block that ball to
make sure it doesn't get by him
are you swinging here 3-0 if it's a good
one no
story for counting
two on one out in the ninth
we talked about it earlier Scott we got
to keep the line moving
don't had to beat a hero right here
don't try to do too much which a lot of
times with the young team you'll see
guys try to do too much but kelnick with
the great at bat having a great day
able to stay within himself
just try to keep the line moving take
your walk
catcher's spot Cal Raleigh do uh there
he is
2012 this walks issued by Ryan Presley
this season
latest to Jared kelnick
now Raleigh
who was crushing the baseball at Triple
A Tacoma this year 324 from the catcher
with a 608 slugging percentage
that's been quieter here in the Biggs
he said he's not handling some pitches
that he destroyed in the miners
should be a good time
to figure it all out
a great time to put it all together this
is a game that the Mariners really need
when you have a you had to blow out on
the first game last night you had a very
very close game that the Mariners would
like to be able to walk away with and
now you find yourself in the same
situation again on the Day game on your
getaway day the only way to create a
happy flight right here today
is to get this win
if you come to Houston and you get swept
it does put a damper on on your feelings
for this playoff push granted you can
pick yourself up even if you don't win
this game but I think this is a big game
I thought last night felt like a big
game as well
I agree and we can say that
in mid-september you know in May okay
all right pulled up but it's
mid-september all right quite a few
teams
in the mix for that Al wild card spot
two of them Seattle's one of those teams
three games back oh Pitch gets away oh
we gotta go we gotta play both Runners
are moving up and in there safely
Maldonado went after the lead Runner
Moore but he got to Third
that's terrifying as the base running
you see the pass ball you make the right
call you see it Ricochet off of the wall
and you know there's about to be a play
right here I gotta go
looks like there was a mix up on Pitch
selection right there
which is why they're going to have a
meeting
maldonado's taking Slaughter
Presley's thinking heater very costly
because now a deep enough Fly ball can
put the Mariners back in front
[Music]
it's called the wild pitch
[Music]
so with one out here with the base open
benefit for presses that you're still in
the bottom of the lineup you would
ideally
like to get the eight hole and nine hole
hitter out right here as opposed to
having to you know allow them to get the
first base and give Crawford another
opportunity to come through in a big
situation like he did yesterday
so now you have a few chances to bury
that signature breaking ball and Escape
here absolutely this is where you trust
your catcher you're going to expand the
Zone you're going to bounce something to
help you get Raleigh to Chase and you'll
trust that Maldonado
will prevent the ball from getting to
the backstop
[Applause]
one two
[Music]
that's trust right there
Maldonado with work to do this afternoon
[Applause]
perfect form keeping the ball in the
middle of his body taking it off the
track the chest protector knowing that
he's saving and running and and
accepting that pressure
he's telling this picture trust me I got
you
does he tried again at 2-2
no swing from Raleigh
throws in for strike three in the second
punch out of the day for Ryan Presley
[Music]
and right here out of his hand he's
seeing that slider Spin and he's
assuming that ball is gonna drop the
same way the previous pitch did but this
almost had a backup slider effect to it
to where it stayed up and rode through
the zone and he knew it right away that
it was a strike borderline pitch
it's a naked eye it looks like a stripe
Ryan Presley is not a fun a b
[Applause]
now it's Jose marmalejos
Martin Maldonado stealing the show
behind the plate making another big stop
strikeouts book ending a single and a
walk for the Mariners here in the ninth
a wild pitch moving both Runners up
and the Mariners known for being so good
with Runners and scoring position have
stranded 12 Runners today
[Music]
parmale hooks up the middle he comes
through the Mariners grabbed the lead
back with one and here comes another
Dylan Moore and Jared kelnick score it's
6-4 Seattle
huge hit for marmaleos right there to
come through a clutch situation did he
take advantage of the shift again
Chef is coming to play a lot today that
is a ground ball right at the shortstop
covers that pitch off the plate stays
through it right at the shortstop you
would be out of the inning
when you're you're Presley's sitting
there
I guess the shift give it some tickets
away too just like the left field wall
it's a ground ball that's a ground ball
and a pitching change that'll do it for
Ryan Presley Blake Taylor will take over
for Dusty Baker's Houston Astros now
down by two stay tuned because the
Astros were down by two yesterday and we
know how that one finished up
I'd probably be embarrassed if I
actually knew how much money I spend on
Tripoli a month can you give me a hint
can I call a friend Marco Polo dang it
I'm like I'm gonna go out on a limb
that's Justice Sheffield I don't know I
mean I feel like he would just be
irresponsible with Chipotle money
that is Justice all right sweet I knew
it
who who thinks Chipotle needs to have a
burrito wrapping seminar they have a
burrito wrapping seminar for those
workers who have no clue no clue how to
wrap one
this is somebody who's never worked a
day in their life probably
someone's sassy is that Chef too you
know is he going on that chipotle rant
no I'm gonna go with like Mitch haniger
[Music]
sassy we described an outfit or a sassy
huh I don't know because he's he would
he would be sassy about people
being terrible burrito wrappers is it is
it
yeah no
I mean is this from 2013 you guys are
going through my head 10 years ago
honey that's so mean why would you say
that I have a little compassion
thank you
it's the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube shorts
watching create videos on YouTube try
shorts and YouTube app on your phone
another dramatic game on YouTube this
week
the Mariners grabbed the lead back in
the ninth from All-Star closer Ryan
Presley who picks up just his third
blown save of the season in 26 chances
and he's now out of the game
as Dusty Baker summons Blake Taylor the
26 year old left-hander here in the
ninth trying to pick up one more out and
then get it to his all-world offense
like Taylor another fastball slider guy
with extreme splits against left hand
and right-handed hitters left-handed
batters batting 123 off of him
right-handers over 305. 305 on base
batting average
well here's your Lefty swinger J.P
Crawford
foreign
did not go
that's Bill Miller over there at third
base
Jose marmalejos
picture there with a few steps off first
the big man of the hour
let's have two strikes on Crawford
marmaleos with a bouncing ball through
the middle
six hole
scores two
Dylan Moore and Jared kelnick make it a
6-4 contest here in the ninth
who's your number nine hitter with the
clutch knock
he had a big season at Triple A too big
big
and coming through clutch in a big
situation it doesn't matter on if
somebody should have been playing the
defense there he hit it where they
weren't
and that was huge for Seattle right here
so for Seawall coming in I'm assuming
he's coming in to close this game he's
going to have his hands full you have
Maldonado who's supposed to lead off you
would assume
that we're going to see bregman in this
situation oh yeah and he had his feet up
in the first inning but I guarantee you
he's in the cage right now getting ready
for this big at bat need to get to
Altuve and Brantley
I'll show you how all of the drama
unfolded
yesterday I mean I think bregman sleeps
with that bat so
he is a baseball Junkie
and show up to this Ballpark and take
swings in the cage at midnight
just for fun if you can't sleep
and if Seawall comes in I'm curious to
see how he pitches him today
Crawford drives one to deep right field
Tucker looking back and forget about it
it's gone JP
Chrome
huge hit hanging slider
he says he doesn't care about the splits
JP's listening to the broadcast I don't
care about the Lefty on Lefty split see
why
he hangs it
I'll bang IT muscle up Mr leadoff man
pick extra tube for Seattle
[Applause]
seventh home run of the Season just the
fourth home run in his career off a
left-handed pitcher and that is just a
hanging slider spinning right over the
middle of the Middle Field as soon as he
hit he's looking at his dugout
now haniger Hot Shot handled nicely by
Gonzalez and wow what a pick by guriel
overhead first
JP Crawford adds on two more for the M's
after the marmolejo's two-run single a
four spot for Seattle saying don't sweep
us please we need this game
Paul seawalt against the team that came
back and won it in extras last night
next
gorgeous evening for baseball here in
Minute Maid Park the Astros opening day
and it's 6-1 St Louis Astros have lost
seven in a row Lois scoring team in
major league baseball 15 and 30 is an
ugly start and that's a big hill to
overcome
[Applause]
this game tied 6-6 in the bottom of the
18th inning
[Music]
[Applause]
this ballpark is just ready to erupt
they're down to run one went away
[Applause]
you know what every single guy in our
ball Club says this is the way it's
supposed to be that game is gone let's
get on to the next game
they're down to one out
Fly ball in the right field and the
Houston Astros are going to the World
Series for the first time in franchise
history
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is 8-4 Seattle they put up four
against Ryan Presley and Blake Taylor in
the ninth inning to build up an
advantage heading into the last of the
ninth and
FYI they did review this play to end the
ninth the top portion of it and newly
guriel did in fact keep that foot on the
back
so inning over
it's all good
it's all great right now for Scott
service in the Seattle Mariners until
they look up and realize that
Dusty Baker gets to Place Alex breckman
in this game as his pinch hitter bragman
with the two run home run to save the
day for Houston in the ninth yesterday
against
the man on the mound now Paul Seawall
trying to shut the door for Seattle with
a four run Edge
he's been awesome this year here's
another pitcher that completely
transformed himself from his days with
the New York Mets spent a lot of time
with that organization moves over to
Seattle and he is a really difficult
look
low arm angle 31 years old and V2 is
having a career gear out of the Seattle
Bullpen over 15 strikeouts per nine
innings
[Applause]
he's a guy who just drops and drives
that fastball I mean it's a fastball
slider Guy The Homer he gave off of gave
up to bregman yesterday was very rare
for him first Homer he's allowed in the
first Homer he's allowed on the fourth
seamer all year long
it was a 93 mile an hour fastball
yesterday from Seawall that was put over
the wall
and the first home run for bregman since
June 9th
that's very common for a pitcher if I
give up a home run to you on a certain
pitch and next at bet I'm gonna come
right at you with that same pitch to
show you that I'm not scared to throw it
to you
[Music]
and it came with two fastballs
challenging bregman right out the gate
and bregman is probably thinking about
the slaughter because he's thinking I I
took you deep yesterday on the fastball
such a mental game we play
on both sides I like just watching
okay bregman stays alive
last night Astros down two not anymore
Gregory with the big Homer big two run
Homer yesterday and the reason he got to
that fastball is the seawall couldn't
find his slider to breckman early in the
count to where he had to come with the
fastball
practice seems like he sees him pretty
well though
let's have some good good at bats off
the Seawall
yeah I mean they matched up
twice in the past week bregman's two for
two against him
he's in 357 since coming back from the
IL missed a couple months
and you have that
Gauntlet waiting after bregman goes the
other way and that is going to drop in
the corner as a foul ball
some hitters just have their guys that
they're able to see better than others I
mean Seawall makes so many players look
uncomfortable
and then you get breckman in the box and
it seems like he's able to see
everything that he's throwing
Seawall trying to re-establish itself
after this after the last game he really
got in trouble with the big walk to
Altuve which set up the Homer to bregman
so in today's game he says I'm gonna go
ahead and attack the strike zone and go
up right after bregman and make these
guys you know hit the ball I mean four
run cushion changes the game and changes
your mindset as well though
bregman's mostly been pulling the
baseball lately and he does just that to
the Crawford boxes he's got another
you have your guys
this is becoming a thing right here
Swagman go long
eight five no outs in the ninth
back to back night bregman off of
Seawall
[Music]
[Applause]
that Crawford home run may end up being
bigger
than initially seen
this game is far from over with this
Astros offense
[Applause]
now Jose Altuve in the top of the order
for the ash show Seewald starts him with
a strike
oh
was that second row first let's see
first row knocked the hat off the front
row into the Crawford boxes
[Music]
[Applause]
bregman had the day off up until that
point
pinch hit Holmen now all to that
who homered in the fifth
bregman against seawalt is turning into
Chris Young against Chris Carpenter you
know what I'm saying Chris Carpenter was
my guy 11 for 18 two home runs for Cy
and there's no way to describe it
because he was a he was a great pitcher
I mean gray guy made everybody look
uncomfortable but for some reason when I
got in the Box I saw the ball like a
watermelon and it just happens for some
guys on two beta Center but he got under
that one
calnick
fading in
there's one that's a big out right there
for the momentum yeah you get past the
Home Run solo home runs normally don't
kill you but to that next hit or two out
two way that's a big at bat I mean if he
walks out too late it becomes a little a
little sketchy about two way gets ahead
it becomes a little sketchy for him to
get that out right there allows him to
settle back in and go try to go ahead
and get back to what he does and finish
this game out
when you go back to the a B for bregman
you saw six pitches all of them were in
the zone even though it was O2
they're all in the zone and seem like
bregman was all over every pitch it
didn't matter if it was a fastball or a
slider he was able to get the barrel to
the ball Grant if he pulled it Fowler
hit it the other way foul he was on the
pitches and he's able to see the ball
big off a seawall why not try and
kind of coax him into chasing a pitch
waste one at O2 no
easier said than done I'm sure he was
trying yeah Brantley to Center but again
gets under it and kelnick this time will
back up a few steps
very similar spot
with an 8-5 score in the ninth a four
run top of the inning for Seattle gives
us some extra options for today's
YouTube player of the game Abraham Toro
Jared kelnick who tied this one up at
four marmalejos had the go-ahead knock
to make it
6-4 and JP Crawford with that two-run
job
those are your options poll opens now
weaker yell waving a miss
quick give this your pick I'm a big
marmaleos guy especially if the score
stays right here where it is if you get
the game-winning hit game-winning RBI
and you got a couple hits that has to
play I'm with your partner
Brielle
Sky's one
and here's Raleigh game over
the Seattle Mariners topped the Houston
Astros on a Wednesday afternoon by a
final score of eight to five and they
Salvage a game in this three-game set
and they inch a little bit closer in the
American League West standings they are
now five and a half back of Houston and
also just two and a half games out of a
wild card seat
great game there by the Mariners being
able to come through another close game
and doing what they do it's not a
one-run game but it felt like a one-run
game when it's all said and done able to
come through late Bullpen lock it down
great at bats by marmolejo Crawford
kelnick late in the game to keep the
pressure on and escape with the win and
have a happy flight at Seattle's
specialty winning close games late let's
talk all about it 30 minutes devoted to
the Mariners and the Astros and this
type ball game or right now
this is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube post game show presented by
YouTube shorts it's a done deal the
Mariners do have a happy long flight
back as they take a win over the Houston
Astros Seattle's off tomorrow and then
they start up a six-game home stand with
three against Arizona a team they just
swept and then three against the Boston
Red Sox a team that they're chasing for
a wild card seat so this is schedule
which we'll get into a little bit more
in a few looks I would say favorable
just based on the fact that Seattle
either is taking on some weaker
opponents or some teams that they are
chasing in the standings and this was a
huge W and just an absolute pleasure to
call it Scott Braun along with Chris
Young Cy yeah this was Titus can be back
and forth and we saw both teams show off
some of their best strengths and they
needed to escape today with the win
coming off those first two losses to
start this series I said coming into
this series if you're playing the Astros
it's understandable if you don't win the
series but you can't come in and get
swept especially when you're getting the
opportunity to go home and play Arizona
a team that you should beat you like
your chances against them this sets up
that home stand that you have coming up
yeah bring some momentum into that six
game home stand for Seattle and whoever
takes that second wild card in the
American League is gonna go on a run at
some point over the next three weeks
because there are quite a few teams
involved so who's going to get hot the
Mariners actually were surging right
before this series they had won five in
a row Astros take the first two in this
series on Monday and Tuesday but Seattle
pulls up a w and they had a lead that
they gave up Houston was up by two at
one point and then Seattle battles back
thanks to Jared kelnick we'll get you
all of the highlights in just a few but
we have some other business to take care
of first including the U2 player of the
game which we'll do in just a moment and
also a couple post-game interviews that
we'll go over nice first game to have
you on here
come back anytime and hang out with us
for the next 30 minutes too right here
on YouTube and let's bring in the big
man Jose marmalejos comes through with
the two RBI knock as the Seattle
Mariners took the lead over Seattle in
the ninth inning thanks to marmalejos
against the All-Star Ryan Presley and
Jose joins us right now Jose
congratulations on the w and the big hit
and first off just take us through that
at-bat against one of the better relief
pitchers in Major League Baseball what
did you see thank you so much guys I
really appreciate it and honestly um I
was just looking to stay short not get
uh too long of a swing or anything just
have a good swing like for the team you
know so I was looking for something out
and over and I just happened to get it
right there and just try to put the the
bat to the ball honestly didn't try to
do too much and it worked out it feels
awesome it is a major blessing yeah that
was great Jose Chris Young here man
seeing you in that situation be able to
take a ball off the plate and take it
through the middle of the field it
doesn't matter about the shift or
whatever it may be you were able to put
the bat on the ball and make something
happen for your team with the loss that
y'all had yesterday how big was that for
you to be able to come through in that
situation I mean it's a major question
like I said like I said and I mean it's
always it's always ratifying to be able
to you know to do something to help your
team win you know and this this came in
a big moment and I'm truly thankful for
the opportunity and like trusting me to
put me in the lineup and everything so
thankful we're with this team and it's
awesome to have this win and um take it
back to a home stand Jose are you also
thankful for the ship sometimes it burns
hitters in the big leagues but this time
it went to a spot where Carlos Correa
might usually be so what did you think
about the placement of the baseball I
mean they're like I have a saying
sometimes it's all about the placement
and right there it worked out you know
like yeah shifts will mess you up
sometimes but you know worked out and
I'm so thankful so blessed and because
of that hit the fans vote you as the
YouTube player of the game here comes
the trophy and get ready okay I know
you're a big strong dude
thank you I appreciate it how does that
feel that that feels amazing this this
feels amazing it's really nice look at
this it's got some weight to it it'll
have your name on it we'll get it
engraved for you as this is a special
day with the Mariners being watched
worldwide on YouTube and picking up a
huge win did it have a playoff feel in
terms of the intensity I mean we saw a
ton of pitchers in this game I believe
for Houston there were I think eight
pitchers that were in the game for Dusty
Baker's crew you had bullpens that were
saved up you have off days for both
teams tomorrow so what was the feeling
in The Dugout about how this game was
playing out from a strategic standpoint
I don't know for sure it felt if the
adrenaline was there we wanted to just
get out there and play baseball and just
try to win a pitch after pitch in a
fight
we were locked in like the team never
gave up we were we were grinding and
like this this team is amazing you know
everybody wants to wants to be there
want to get it done and we're
left-handed I mean it's just a blessing
like we get this win and we got taken
home and just keep it going keep it
rolling happy flight right yeah happy
flight for sure to be able to come
through in that big situation you had to
big double Off the Wall the base hit to
take the lead how do you think your team
will be able to carry this momentum to
play against Arizona when you get home I
don't know for sure I mean the work
ethic here is amazing and um I will tell
you that this is a team that will not
give up and like just with the work
ethic grinding every single day being
like having the concentration to keep
going I mean this this is a really
special team it's a really good team you
had a special season at AAA this year
too you were crushing the baseball you
were among the AAA West leaders this
season so how did you feel your season
went in AAA and then how do you try and
carry that momentum into the big leagues
are there certain aspects of your game
that stood out this year that you want
to make sure are continuing in the big
leagues for this stretch run definitely
a major blessing to this season that I
had in AAA for sure and um I just I just
want to keep on working every single day
on the work ethic don't get ahead of
myself just trusting that everyday
process that was working for me don't
try to get ahead or think about the past
just live in the moment and at the same
time just trusting the work ethic of
every day and trusting my my my coaches
and teammates
I love the energy I love the mindset
Jose where will you put that trophy in
your house though oh this is gonna be
right next to the TV so I could just see
it
makes sense right you stream YouTube
onto your TV and it's right next to you
and we'll send you one with your name on
it Jose congratulations on the victory
on winning YouTube player of the game
have a happy flight and good luck the
rest of the way in this fight for a
postseason spot for Seattle thank you
very much guys I truly appreciate it you
guys have a good one you too thanks Jose
is your YouTube player of the game at
the trophy it was tight look at this
race this was one of the tighter races
we had this year Mariners fans and
everyone else watching here on YouTube
say that Jose marmalejos is the player
of the game 31 of the pie but everyone
was at 20 plus so it was a team
contribution for this victory that helps
to tell this story and we'll give you
much more on the game story in a moment
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
strike three
[Applause]
a great play
I talked about his Fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
something like this is what they came
for
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
what a finish to this one between the
Mariners and the Astros Astros took the
first two in the series and then the
Mariners grab the last meeting in 2021
in the regular season between Seattle
and Houston here at Minute Maid Park
Scott Braun and Chris Young watching the
highlights of this game and how it
played out if you missed anything it
looked like this
Abraham Toro fits to mold as he digs in
with the bases loaded Toro grips one to
right field plenty of open space he's in
business and the Mariners crack the
scoreboard first here's hanager and
Seeger will score as well it's a two RBI
two bagger for Abraham Toro and he
continues to punish his former Squad now
it's Correa Mr walk-off man from
yesterday in the 10th
he rips that one right into the club at
the hot corner of Kyle Seeger wow that's
rocket retrieval right there that's when
you go into the Dugout and everybody
says nice swing and you're like man I'm
not trying to hear that that should have
taken his glove off of his hand right
there
so Alvarez at first went out for Tucker
Tucker into left Center kelnick chasing
it and it's going to hop up against the
wall Alvarez heading for third he's
being waved home and here he comes throw
is
not in time the Astros are on the board
it's an RBI double for Kyle Tucker to
bring home Alvarez and make it two to
one now marwin Gonzalez some huge hits
in his Houston career he played with the
Astros from 2012 to 2018. Gonzalez takes
off to the Crawford boxes forget about
it the Astros grabbed the lead 3-2 off a
two-run shot from marwin Gonzalez
welcome back to Houston Marvin nice
homecoming right there huh two out
Seeger at second base here is Terence
Mariners down 3-2 here's the pitch
it's an off-speed pitch pulled to the
left side on a slide as Gonzalez gets up
and throws out to her ends beautiful
play to his left for Marvin Gonzalez
doing what he does and we'll go to the
bottom of the third at Minute Maid Park
the Astros lean it three to two Abraham
Toro is one for two and hits the first
pitch the other way left center field
Myers chasing it and he's
got the baseball
now heading back to First and in there
safely is Kyle Seeger Jake Myers with
the closing speed wow what a catch what
a great play the lead off man Homer
yesterday 2-1
is rips left field does he have it on
back-to-back days
he does Jose altuved in Homer for about
a month goes along yesterday and doubles
up this afternoon it's number 27 on the
season make it 4-2 Houston
and we keep rolling in the seventh first
and third two outs film Eton into the
game oh it just takes one pitch for
Jared kelnick to like it
one's off the wall and it scores two and
it ties the game at four Cy and that's
when things really turned up and Seattle
knew at this point we got our clutch
knock from a rookie now we need to put
this game away but there's a lot more
action still second and third two outs
tied France is the batter and I mean he
has come up clutch so often for Seattle
but this time Marvin Gonzalez is able to
put him away and preserve this 4-4 game
and that brings us to Carlos Correa
against Diego Castillo in the eighth and
Castile was like man and we're looking
at him like what's what's he upset about
Castile had his stuff working today he
had that Sinker slider combo
Down In the Zone off the plate expanding
and had the Astros on their heels yeah
and he struck out the side after that no
big deal in the ninth this is Jose
marmaleos Mr YouTube player of the game
he's putting the trophy right next to
the TV at home
and that's the ideal of hitting it where
they ate yeah I mean he he had some big
head bats had a double earlier in the
game and then Crawford comes up to put a
little cushion on it gives Seawall some
cushion to come out and finish the game
off and close it out other than the
Homer to breakfast yeah which you know
it happens on back-to-back days hello
homers whatever
they had a four run lead which really
helped then it was three then it was
guriel
foul grounds and the Mariners securing
an 8-5 W over the Houston Astros Houston
drops to 81 and 52 on the season or make
that 81-58 Seattle is now 76 and 64 in
the year Astros still in a comfortable
spot five and a half games up in the AL
West the Mariners are two and a half
games away from a playoff seat that
second Wild Card let's get more on this
game and another interview Brett Dolan
take it away
certainly Scott well the Seattle
Mariners won an Extra Inning game for
the 15th time this season today that is
by far and away the most in Major League
Baseball now to do that you need some
later than hits which they were able to
get in kind in that 10th inning you also
need contributions from some Big Time
Players earlier in games even some of
those guys that started the year as
Houston Astros like Abraham Toro had a
chance to catch up to Abraham just a few
moments ago
joined by Abraham Toro first of all
Abraham after last night how big was
this win for the Mariners oh you know it
just feels good to bounce back uh
yesterday was it was a tough for us but
you know it's a guy we came some
attitude and we have some good at bats
and you know we we got that relevant in
it and that felt good you had one of
those good at bats early and knocked in
a couple of runs with a double you have
14 RBIs against your former team what is
it about the focus in these head-to-head
at mats well it's something like I know
a lot about them but they know a lot
about me so it's just that adjustment I
was able to do my homework and you know
it paid off when I'm thinking about your
situation with the Seattle Mariners I'm
thinking about two playoff shares one
from the Astros one for the Mariners
what would it take for Seattle to make a
run to get into this postseason some way
somehow you know just our our pitches
are being really good you know they've
been a lot of low scoring games and you
know just the offense is starting to
click and I think you know if we keep
going we can we can make a push or
playoffs congratulations on the win all
right thank you it's Abraham tour
you watch Abraham Toro or marmoleus just
a few moments ago with the guys there's
one thing that stands out Smiles right
winning is supposed to be fun this is an
organization that is trying to build to
be relevant in September they've been
able to pick up some key wins I know
last night certainly stung today though
able to sneak what away from the Houston
Astros and certainly they're enjoying
the ride for this final game of this
road trip before they head home to try
and find a little more magic in Seattle
Mariners though win in 10 Innings today
over the Houston Astros will step aside
and return to Minute Maid Park right
after this
foreign
[Music]
there are few moments like it
moments that compare to arriving here
and despite all of us going to the same
place
we all come for different reasons
some come for the sights
the sounds
[Music]
some come for the bombs
some for the bonds
some come for passion
some come for the plays
we all come to be part of something
bigger than ourselves
regardless of what you come for
there's a ticket for you Astros season
tickets
for the h
ormone
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
at Minute Maid Park in Houston inside
hot day out there I mean you live right
around the corner this is the regular
weather we've been dealing with over the
past month plus right mid 90s you're
feeling it too a little sweat this is
summertime in Houston quite a bit of
humidity in the air so I'm very grateful
that they had that roof closed today
because if they did not we would
definitely be feeling that heat yeah no
sweat all right inside here at Minute
Maid Park temperature controlled Astros
had grabbed the first two in this series
and then they fall to Seattle 8-5 is
your final score for the YouTube game of
the week Scott Brown along with Chris
Young Cy here for the first time with us
on YouTube this season and we've had
Houston a few times this year and we've
gushed over all of the strengths of this
team because there are many there's a
reason why they're leading the American
League West and they look like one of
the juggernauts in Major League Baseball
there just aren't many flaws at the
moment there was one it was the bullpen
and then they picked up three four
pieces and it's made a huge difference
for this club and yes I know the bullpen
did not help things out today they did
ultimately give things up with Ryan
Presley and the blown save but you look
at this team and how they're loaded up
for the postseason it's a special
talented club they're a special club and
in the American League you have the
Astros in my in my opinion in the
National League you have the Dodgers
don't think those are the top two those
are two complete teams that are primed
and ready for the playoffs you have plus
starting pitching Granite Astros don't
have the Superstar names like the
Dodgers have but the guys that they have
they have five six quality starters that
can go out there and give you a good
five six seven innings in the playoffs
on top of that you have a dominant
offense we saw that today no matter if
you're top of the lineup or all the way
down to the seven eight hole especially
with bregman in the lineup every day
you don't have any holes you don't have
any holes and you have Maldonado at the
bottom who's catching a great game and
you know running the pitching staff
perfectly so you have in the AL the
Astros over the race if you had to guess
right now do you think there are more
complete ball Club than Tampa Bay when
I'm watching as the fan
I would favor the Astros I understand
what the numbers may go against that I
understand all the things that the raids
have done this season just as a fan of
the game when I watch these two teams
play the Astros the Rays have been there
before as well but the Astros are primed
and I feel like if they get to the
playoffs they're going to be a handful
oh and if it's Astros Dodgers in the
World Series haven't we seen that in the
recent past do those teams like each
other are they friends though no not too
much and I don't know if the fan how the
fans feel about each other either so I'm
sure it will be fun I would be okay with
another Astros Dodgers World Series I
think the world would be okay with all
the drama that would bring to the mix so
we also loved having Cal Riley with the
microphone until he was as needed in the
game as well later on but Cal thank you
and we want to hear the best from Cal
today and also keep in mind he caught
the final out in this game so first off
how did he sound on the microphone
foreign
my uncle has a normally large hands he
has
at the time
I still think it is it's the biggest
World Series ring ever made
he does for the Marlins really was it 03
or O2
he didn't know his ring size so he went
to a ring store he actually just told
the story the other day went to a ring
or like a jewelry whatever to get sized
right here I get size so he went and
they didn't have anything that fit him
and it was a 17. and a half
I don't know what do they do halves
the biggest thing you've ever seen his
his sausage fingers
I had a I went on a kick in high school
where I really wanted to a pair of
Converse shoes
I don't know why like the high tops Like
Larry Bird like black yeah from Sandlot
and all that so I went on a kick and oh
I just wanted the black and white pair
of the body to rock them though
I think you gotta copy like a skater boy
the rock those they're like
You Gotta Wear like tight pants and like
you can't wear them with shorts because
they're high tops
it's just not my style I can just say
this like this I think they're cool you
can rock them
somebody asked me that one time
you said so here
he said so you're you're switchinger
right I said yeah I said so
that means you're amphibious
I was like what you're amphibious you
hit both ways
not exactly
this is this is my chance I get I have
an audience now
if Cody Jinks hears this I'm going to
your concert
this off season so
it's always found me
it's not like he's my walk-up song or
anything
okay I gotta make sure that I reach out
to Cody Jinks and his team and we hook
up Cal Raleigh especially for being on
YouTube with us all right we're gonna
make sure that connection happens I'm
telling you it'll be on maybe the last
YouTube game of the year that we do or
maybe next week even you know we'll be
close to Hollywood gotta make something
happen right there I'm gonna work on
that for you Cal okay and also you work
on getting this team back into the
postseason for the first time since 2001
now it might not look favorable for them
in the division out there in the West in
the American League but the Wild Card
just continues to get tighter Blue Jays
two back out the Mariners are just two
and a half away they have leapfrogged
over the A's over the past week as
Oakland has sputtered they've lost four
in a row and the Yankees and the Red Sox
keep coming down to earth and making us
think
is this the year that the Seattle
Mariners snapped the longest active
playoff drought among the four major
North American Pro Sports do you think
it could happen I think it could happen
and this is a position that they put
themselves into I think if you go to
them at the beginning of this season
and tell them there'll be a couple of
games out you know two and a half games
out of the wild card would you take that
position I think they would take it
right here you'll be Boston I feel like
one if not both have to give I think I
think Boston could be the one to
potentially fall out of there the Blue
Jays have been playing well they've been
a team that I've picked a click all year
long it just hasn't worked out for them
but they have a great team and another
great offense in the American League
you know eventually they'd like to get
into the World Series too because it
hasn't happened for them and it's the
longest active pennant drought in Major
League Baseball and it's 45 seasons for
Seattle now even if it doesn't happen
this year you're looking at a ball club
that has according to mlb.com the number
two ranked farm system so when you
combine what they're doing on the field
right now and kelmick for example is not
on that list anymore he's not a prospect
okay they still have four players in the
top 40 according to MLB pipeline there
is a lot of Promise there's a core that
is starting to build with the major
league club but then there is a ton of
Talent on the way for a Seattle team
that's not just thinking about
making it to the post-seasoning Gap
they're trying to build a winner with
sustained success to have the Prospect
Capital you could call it which helps
you of course for your big league ball
Club but also with trades they'll have
money to spend this off season there is
a lot of Hope suddenly the rain is
starting to settle the precipitation is
starting to go away the Mariners are
about to be in a situation to where they
could be a really good ball Club you
don't want if your ownership you don't
want to go go out there and spend too
much money too early if your team isn't
primed and ready but right now I think
they're in a great position you have
Kyle Lewis will be coming back playing
center field that moves Kelling it back
to right field you have Rodriguez was a
huge Prospect coming up who just played
in the Futures game Julio Rodriguez
number two ranked Prospect in all
baseball who's coming in yet number two
ranked and like that's a dominating
Outfield if kelnik can get back to form
so with that being said you have three
guys out there that you're not paying a
lot of money you have a lot of cap Room
free you have some money to spend the
Mariners are not a small Market team a
lot of people assume the Mariners are a
small Market team but they're not they
have money to spend and they can go out
there and make a q a few key additions
and be a really good ball Club some
pictures an infielder or two hey there
are a ton of shortstops that could be
available this off season I know JP
Crawford's been great he can potentially
either stay there or move to another
spot there's a lot that they can do
and hey let's take you back to Jake
Myers covering a ton of ground statcast
powered by Google Cloud 10 catch
probability means that was a really
tough play to make I'm sitting next to a
center fielder and you know despite him
not diving or going all I mean he went
all out just in a different way that is
very difficult to pull off so we bring
up our curious creators segment and
secret base who had our creator
Spotlight today wants to say I think I
pulled something watching Jake make that
play very nice of your base and that
play is a play you see this 10
probability of making that play that's a
play that normally only the home field
team will make mainly because Jake knows
this outfill he's comfortable with this
Outfield Dusty Baker told us before the
game that he's very comfortable with
Myers and center field because he's able
to make plays like this I mean that ball
is five feet
to the left of that wall that's jutting
out right there and that could have been
a very dangerous play but with great
communication from left field right
there and Jake being very comfortable
with Minute Maid Park he's able to make
that play and get the ball back in he
looks like he's been doing it in this
field for years Jake Myers makes a big
play Astros fall though to the Mariners
two more games to go next week on Friday
a night game between the A's fighting
for a playoff spot and shohei Otani and
the angels and then Cardinals Brewers
the Brewers in control of the central
the Cardinals fighting for a wild card
oh we have two good ones on the docket
for the rest of the way see why this was
awesome man did you enjoy it I had a
great time it's great to be able to do
this in my home field great to be able
to be here with you and thank you for
allowing me it's a man to poop with you
you crushed it and then a quick trip
home for you too which is absolutely
enjoy that the MLB game of the week Live
on YouTube swings back Friday A's Angels
shohei Otani time meet us there it's a
Friday night game our pregame show
starts up at 9 Eastern and for my
friends Chris Young Brett Dolan and our
entire Superstar crew I'm Scott Braun
logging out for now we'll see you next
time next week on Friday night
foreign
[Music]
[Music]